alright guys bangbang I've got Dave here
thanks for doing this
yeah my pleasure you are very well known
on Twitter you are the king of hot takes
which end up not being so hot and
actually end up being more accurate than
not but for those that don't know you
what is your background how do you get
to be a professor at Cornell that's a
little twisted so as a kid I was not a
wonderful student I had bursts of
activity that were good but I you know
sort of sex drugs rock and roll a lot of
sports stuff like that I would not have
gotten into Cornell if it were not for
the fact that my grandfather controlled
every penny into the University basic
and talent he is a vice chancellor the
Board of Regents and the National alumni
president so you know that kind of gets
you in the door
majored and by I was gonna go to vet
school to med school and then decide
last minute to do chemistry so took my
bio degree went to Columbia won became a
chemist thought I was gonna flunk out
got pretty close actually because they
made me take some gradual level physics
course I didn't have calculus show like
that and and then not locking my PhD
project Mirko nice 1980 Rush beating the
Russians right so I got my PhD in about
two and a half years and no postdoc and
got an unsolicited interview from
Cornell to come back and so I went
honest here's the interview trips and
came back at the ripe old age of 25 so
even though I'm not that old I'm 65 I've
been here for for 41 years 40 years and
and and then and then how do I get to
you and I talk and that's a ridiculous
question
somehow I I start paying attention in
the markets as an aging boomer and
started to realize that they're more
screwed up than I thought they're
supposed to be so I was a wild ball in
the tech period and then I'd start doing
valuation analyses which weren't hard
because they had no valley
and and and then became a bear and once
you go bearish it's very hard to come
back it's a it's a it's a kind of a
one-way street because once you start
looking at the world as a through the
sort of the darkness and so I try to
hedge inflation got into energy the
inflation never should have energy did
really well it eventually took back a
chunk of it but uh got in the goal that
you know 290 down to 270 I can't
remember what got me in the goal and
then so I had about three decades which
things were sort of brilliantly for an
uneducated fool and then and then the
last decade I just I've existed in it in
complete disbelief that that it's a
rational market and so I've been on the
sidelines I've done okay but uh but I
didn't catch the wave I think really
sincerely someone asked and your
question on Twitter you know why is he
still bearish it I think the markets
have literally been screwed up for ten
years and I think in you know nine they
got they reached about fair value and
you go well you know no they were dirt
cheap no they'd fall on countless tens
of thousands of feet but they weren't
cheap I had dinner with what another one
of those how did you get here Dave
moments I dinner with Mark Spitz neg on
he said yeah they were cheap you're
below fair value for about a week
Grantham said the same thing so so I was
not alone and I just didn't believe that
they would bounce and then not plummet I
thought we were gonna do a total repeat
of saved the thirties and what I didn't
see coming and I've never met anyone who
did was a Federal Reserve that would
that would do have sex with sheep and in
plain sight to to save the system but no
matter what the cost and so for the last
ten years the Federal Reserve Kevin
wharfs actually said it's unfortunate
they treated every single day as though
or an emergency I think that was a
pretty good way of putting it so so I
just I missed the last ten years you
know
Gold's done well lately and so I you
know if I don't screw up I'll retire
tremendous comfort but I can't buy
something I don't
there's traders everywhere now I can't
buy something that if it goes bad I
would I wouldn't be able to forgive
myself that that's the filter I put
everything through if I'd make this
decision it goes bad was was it was it
still a good decision if the answer is
yes then I'm fine by him and so buying
into these markets if it had gone bad on
me I wouldn't have forgiven myself so I
have people hammering me saying you know
you're just an idiot you know you're
just wrong when you gotta admit it I
think I'm still right actually I just
think it's taken longer than I could
have imagined because it's amazing what
you know thirty trillion two hours will
do you know what one of the things
that's very interesting to me is you
have a day job that has nothing to do
with finance at least on the surface
teach organic chemistry what are the
overlaps that you see between that world
of kind of very science driven and very
kind of I think different than
mainstream thinking and the financial
markets like why do you have an interest
in both of those two things I think the
most important thing that I took away so
when I was I was always contrary and
right now which is always contrarian and
and sometimes being con trained just me
does make you wrong but I am when I when
I got the corn out the ripe old age of
25 having really smashed some PhD
records I realized I had to move on I
moved into a field that everyone said
was dead I had so many people say was
dead right we know what that's called
that's called the bottom right and I
kept saying you know no one's been in
this field for like 20 years you think
it's possibly there are some important
questions now to answer and so I went
into it I barely survived tenure I mean
maybe it was easy but but it sure as
hell was risky as hell for me I mean it
was just so contrary and it took my 15
years again going but I ended up going
into a field called organolithium
chemistry which turns out to be is
complicated as any field of wet
chemistry of there's chemists listening
I think they would agree and I had a
very famous chemist and you'll never
figure this stuff out I said I think I
can he says you know we look back and
forth and I did in my opinion I did it's
still an empty field in some sense
there's users everywhere so it's a
profoundly used field but the people
willing to sort of dig in and wrestle
with the Python to understand the stuff
that barely exists and so I and so in
that sense I'm not a leader because
people didn't follow me
but for 41 years I survived doing this
getting funding from NIH even though
National Institutes of Health even
though people would say how do you
connect that with health and now I can
but I'm getting phenomenal scores I mean
the study sections can see the health
law I new collaborations with Pharma the
health relatedness is very real during
that 30 to 40 years of doing this
particular area of chemistry I am I
found that an essentially every project
we ever did someone was profoundly wrong
and so we'd study something that people
say well we kind of know how that works
you know each time we go it's not even
close and and when you looked at the
answer you go makes total sense it's
just not what anyone thought and that
has been going on for four decades and I
can't even get it right myself and so I
will start a project and I'll think a
lot and do this before I know what's
gonna happen
and then it won't happen and so so what
it taught me the most important thing is
it taught me that the experts with
massive resumes can can all be wrong and
I thought of something all about two
years ago and an idea about two years
that I swear to God you could ask a
thousand PhD chemist what's the answer
and they would all agree without fail
all agree with the answer is and I'm
sitting in a seminar when an officer
just clicked I said no that's wrong not
just not quite right it's wrong it's
backwards
and then I went and asked about 200
chemists the question without even a
chalkboard I could convince them they
were wrong and without with one
exception they all got it wrong and I on
this list were Nobel Prize winner stuff
and so it's one of those things where if
you have faith that the experts can be
just dead wrong being a contrarian just
isn't in her so what was it what was the
idea
well the idea for if any chemists are
listening the idea that when you do a
reaction of free particles this is real
basic stuff a and B and C you bring them
together to make a single molecule ABC
what they say is is that you never do
that in a single step you never bring
three particles together simultaneously
do you have any science background
what's your science when I read on the
Internet okay okay so you're an expert
like me then and you never bring them
together simultaneously you always bring
two together then one more and I you
could get a thousand chemists to agree
with that and you say why and the answer
is always something about the
probability of them colliding
simultaneously and that turns out in
scientific terms is to be an entropy
problem that says any tendency probably
mad clever I say interviewing and I go
yeah turns out the entropy is more
favorable for the for the simultaneous
one it's what's called enthalpy which is
he but and it's it's a boring problem
what makes it interesting is that
thousands upon thousands upon thousands
of chemists would all get it wrong it's
one of these things that no one would
even question and so I questioned things
like I found I said I talked to a
thousand money managers on the Roth IRA
about
eight years ago and I presented an
argument that the Roth IRA was
mathematically flawed and that no one
should ever use it
I stood up there and is in Vegas it
wasn't the seminar with that wasn't a
meeting with Cohen Roach who I'm a big
fan of it I watched his seminar finally
your interview with him the other day
but but I gave the second I said it's a
half hour talk and I said if
I'm wrong someone out there tell me and
no one no one was able to correct it and
and why a chemist sitting in ething in
New York because finding a gigantic
pothole in the Roth IRA is beyond me I
don't know why it's fascinating let's
talk about the virus so this thing has
decimated the world both on the
healthcare side and the economic side
we're sort of the health side first you
have to see have a background in science
you've been watching this play out you
know on Twitter and in headlines etc
what's your general sense as to what's
happened and kind of where we are with
the virus right now well I've spent the
entire pandemic thinking in two weeks
I'll know it's just been in two weeks
I'll know so I first at first got you
know there's always something coming out
of the Chinese wet market that's right
there's always those guys will eat
anything that Wiggles right and and so
what caught my attention is the minute
they shut down Wuhan I said oh my god we
just shattered the supply chains right
so I started reaching out to friends I
got I got an email from my Einhorn who's
been so generous with this time a Steven
Roach who's been so generous with this
time and we started sort of swapping war
stories trying to figure it out what
what did it mean but I was convinced
that you can't shut down a major region
of China without destroying the global
supply chain now it hasn't been as bad
as I thought I thought we'd see but but
but I ran into tons of people who said
we're not getting the chips we need
we're not getting this we're not getting
that there could be a delayed reaction
there's even theories out there they
said they shut everything down so no one
would be demanding the supplies right
what an interesting thesis that is right
now I'll entertain any idea until I
shoot at them so in any event the guy
who I think got it right was again one
of your former interviewees Jim Bianco
he was on it fast and furious and so
we're swapping a lot of emails mostly
one direction mostly him just tell me
stuff for me going I agree um and and I
think it's been devastating and it
reminds me it's it's like it's like
someone put up
dynomite in the turkey you blew it up
and then someone else came along so I
put it back together now right it
doesn't work that way so I think we
destroyed the global economy in a very
big way and I think that the people who
think we're just gonna reassemble it are
just are dreaming I could be wrong but I
certainly has a strong opinion Bianco
said one day on Twitter and he got crap
for he said you know 90% recoveries a
disaster
and people said what are you greedy what
are you and I I had to chime in and I
said 90% recovery means 10% drop in GDP
that's a disaster and so and so yeah so
I think I think we're gonna have lots of
missing jobs that don't ever come back
you can't run a restaurant at 50%
capacity you can't run a movie theater
if I'm gonna swatch with masks on and so
the only way we come back as ever and
just says screw it me and the world
which by the way I think they've
collectively are trying to do right one
of the questions I've been trying to
understand it's why about two weeks ago
I've said with no change in the
biomedical story
all of a sudden it just became a now
we're gonna open up and I'm gonna what
was that right there was no you know
all-clear signal that was put out there
do you think it had to do with just it
literally got warmer in various areas so
like literally just springtime hit maybe
it could also be remember Arab Spring
Rimmer were caused Arab Spring some
Tunisian Guy'd lit himself on fire just
one flammable Tunisian and that
triggered and so it could be something
like the that blind relatively hot a
hairstylist who said I'm not closing and
it could be as hell yeah you know the
shot at like Lexington and Concord you
know who knows what but it just changed
it just changed and and all of a sudden
people stopped wearing masks except in
logical places so you seemed at the
store but not walking down the street so
there's just a sea change that occurred
it was it was like people just Randy
they're a lot of people who are critical
saying that's really self
to do that I'm going these people don't
know how they're gonna feed their kids
there's nothing nothing selfish about
that and so it's real easy to sit there
with a paycheck and criticize people who
are and we know what was the stat
something like 40% of the people
couldn't put 400 dollars together if
they had to write those people now can't
we can't put 50 cents together well I
think you're bringing up a couple of
issues right so the first is one of the
things that I'm personally interesting
your opinion right is you spend all day
looking at science and you come from a
mindset where there's a hypothesis you
test it and see they're correct or it's
not you move on you kind of rinse and
repeat that process over and over again
we saw with the virus was a number of
people who they put forth these models
that I'll call them hypothesis right
because no one really knew what was
gonna happen but they were they were
trying to predict how bad could this be
and you'd see models that said you know
worst case base case and best case type
situations what I think now is
transpired is we've got you know a month
or two months of data in the lockdown
and people are saying wait a second
you're telling me that you know an order
of magnitude less people have actually
died than you originally said right and
there's almost like this shock and awe
factor if people were anchored on such
big numbers you know millions of
Americans dying and now all of a sudden
they see the numbers and by the way
there are people who have died right
there's a lot of people who died
actually
it's just nearly as much and it looks
actually like a small number compared to
what the original predictions were and
you think that like the psychology of
that plays into people's been like look
open damn you know economy up yeah you
lied to us I think is another way of
putting it I don't know if this is true
yet so one of the things I will be
watching for and I've been thinking
about is is if the shutdown really did
heroic things to stop the spread well
first and foremost you're gonna have to
explain why other regions of the world
are in a killing field right so we're
not I heard Mexico has three times as
many cases you know BFD it's still not a
big number and and you know Chuck I know
suppose Allison stopped having cases but
I would say da China just a bunch a liar
you know we can write them off Nelson
you go but maybe they're not right maybe
the damn thing is stopped maybe it ran
its course in China and and so now so
the other problem we have is I've been
talking to a lot of biochemist one of my
former students is a biochemist at
Harvard now and he and I spent hours on
the phone chatting with him about how
the virus works and how it you know gets
the RNA into the cells and how the
incubation this guy's glued to it and he
was pretty nervous about the whole thing
so I can't say that the that the serious
biochemists weren't nervous about it but
I was waiting for the numbers to
unequivocally unambiguously exceed
anything normal so when it was in 5,000
or 10,000 we're still sub flu numbers
now I think we're above flu numbers but
there's a there's a there's a problem
with the data being so bad so the data
is bad at two levels first of all what's
the comorbidity at this point in time
some 87 year old guy crashes his
motorcycle
they're calling it covered when some guy
dies my heart attack because he had
Kovan is it really a code of death if he
had gotten simply a mild case the fluid
would have died and so you don't know
how to count second of all I've heard
there's over 90 different tests now I
got tested because I've been feeling
crummy for a while I said why not
my son had and he said why not we went
got tested and they did it all wrong
they did it all wrong they you know if
you do that the nasal tests are supposed
to jam it back there to the point where
you feel like an Egyptian mommy in the
making right and there's a name for when
they pull the brains out through your
nose and and they just swapped it around
her nose and that was it
I go that's not going to test for
anything but 90 different tests you know
you got Elizabeth Holmes probably
running tests out there and so it's
gonna be garbage data right they're all
testing for different markers you can
have Corona flavored RNA in there and
it's testing positive is it four base
pairs five base pairs and
and and that my former student said you
know they don't yet have a good one
doing a lot of statistical analysis then
you got that guy Neil Ferguson who was
out there [ __ ] and to to oppress his
his his 38 year old girlfriend but it's
even worse than that turns out she's a
sort of a as I understand it a
professional activist so he she's out
there you know with all these because
it's often you O'Neill Neil wants
serious action out of this chick now and
so and so his his numbers that
apparently got entire nations to change
their policy was because he want to get
laid right I mean is that destroyed a
nation by the way well so we're talking
about Neil Ferguson from Imperial
College basically created a model that
literally said you know in the United
States are gonna be like five million
people were gonna die I mean some
ridiculously high number and then it
comes out that now he has corrected it
we can correct the number or the model
that now shows lower numbers but then it
came out that he wasn't social
distancing he was basically having an
affair with a woman and all these kind
of implications to it but what
ultimately brings us to is this idea of
bad data right and so from pretty early
on I was in the camp of hey this is real
right I you love this I called my father
who's who's in his 60s and I said hey
man I don't want to have the debate
right all I'm gonna tell you is wash
your hands a little bit more don't go
shaking people saying stay inside a
little bit more and take some vitamin C
and kind of just just chill out right
you don't you don't got to believe that
this is gonna kill you but just kind of
chill out and take it at least a little
bit seriously and before I've been
finished he literally hit me with I take
a multivitamin I'll be fine
Ryan's kind of where his pants hiked up
to his chest and was he bitching about
the government is the question of course
right and so you know it was kind of one
of these things where when you look at
it you say the data has always been
wrong so I took it seriously but also
you can say at the same time that Dan
has been wrong and it's because the
financial incentives are off right all
of a sudden if I'm if I'm at a house
and you say to me hey if you just check
this box and say this person died of
code vid whether you know that to be
true or not whether they tested positive
or not you're gonna get $8,000 $10,000
or hade you put them on a ventilator
they get you know I think it's tens of
thousands of dollars you literally are
using financial incentives from the
government to change the statistics and
it completely throws off how we can
analyze what's actually happening well
so to give credit where credit is due I
think the people early on like Chris
Martenson it was documenting it daily I
think he's doing a great job and I think
he's doing a great service and and he
was obviously very very nervous about
this virus and I don't think he was
wrong because was an unknown it sort of
like when it's 1999 and you're worried
about your tech stocks and they're not
crashing doesn't mean you're not right
and so what Chris was picking up on was
huge risk and there's no question there
was huge risk so I think the people who
dismiss risk eventually become some
Darwinian smudge mark on the road so so
I'm a big believer that when you see
risks oh so I had this funny situation
where I was I was doing podcasts and the
markets were going up and the virus is
getting crazy and I'm going this isn't
making sense to me so the markets were
just crazy you know they talk about you
know you smart guy money manager guys
you know how everything's forward look
and I go these guys couldn't find their
ass for their hands right these guys are
stupid this we've got a global pandemic
we got supply chain problem and they're
not selling anything so I did a podcast
with jelly doughnut now I I did a ton
but the funny thing about this one was
said this is the one where it got famous
right away because the first podcast was
Einhorn because he used the jelly donut
model you know economically and he got
her to do it I've been trying to get her
to do other podcasts like real vision he
won't do it he says I feel bad saying no
Dave um so in any event so he got out
her and so he got him on the map and so
I didn't the jelly donut podcast and and
I talked about the things I've gotten
right in the past the tech stocks and
buying gold and all stuff and then the
other thing I did that was the probably
the best thing ever
it was a 2002 email to a friend of
Goldman and I said that there was a
subprime crisis coming and it was about
a five page email and I said that that
that that that that General Electric was
taken on risk and General Motors was
taking on risk and the banks were taking
a risk and that the subprime mortgages
were picking up which barely go all the
way back around 98 99 it really started
early and that I thought the banking
system was gonna collapse I said so and
I might the only mistake I made in the
damn thing was I thought JP Morgan was
gonna go down and that was precisely
wrong right but but I called it and then
at one point I think was a CAD röszke
right when the great early early blogger
said something in in tweet one I said
you know if you're early you're wrong I
sent him my 2002 write-up I said was I
wrong and and by his model I was I was
wrong and he said now you're splendidly
correct on that so it was a big call you
could be early so in any event so I did
talk about this a gentleman and this was
something like February probably 15th or
something and I said I this is I said I
see minimum 50% correction in these
markets that's that's without even the
virus getting involved right this is
just based on valuation and and then
Business Insider picked up on it and
they wrote you know one of these you
know make submit a jug like this once
came true where they said yeah Ivy
League professor who called the sub
grand crash cause a 50 percent
correction it was just it was the cheesy
thing that we all see right on the Yahoo
homepage or something right and
businesses Eider did this and I'll take
like the day that the podcast got
uploaded the thing started tanking down
on us the funniest goddamn thing I've
ever seen here so but then the Fed is
rallied it back but now I think this
rally is gonna fail I'm not a technical
guy so I hate to use terms like that
because they they pervaded markets right
everyone uses technical language to talk
about stuff that we should be talking
about using valuation language was last
time someone made some reference to
something being cheap not relative to
something else but just flat-out cheap
show me something that's show me
something that's not a great risk of
losing all its revenues it's got a p/e
of 8 it's got no debt right these are
hard to find there but they're gonna get
cheaper at some point in my opinion you
said it earlier right and I think this
is one of the things it cracked me up is
we saw the airline stocks for example go
from I think was United when flying
eighty bucks to twenty dollars and I
literally wrote something I said just
cuz it fell from 80 to 20 doesn't mean
that it's cheap it actually you have to
remember that you know they did I think
it was like eight billion dollars in
revenue last year and the market cap was
not five-and-a-half and it was a look
it's you know trading below the the
revenue last year and I said yeah but
they're not doing eight and a half
billion dollars revenue this year right
here or the following year or the
following year right it's just awful
I've been writing about share buybacks
since I whacked back and checked I've
been writing about share buybacks from
at least 2012 and I went back and looked
at all the different things I said I've
been railing on him but this year I went
bananas on Twitter because I could see
as they were as they were cranking up
the Boro right the BIR to bail everyone
out I said they're gonna bail out the
goddamn airlines and these guys have
taken every penny that they have and put
it towards these pump-and-dump
by Mac schemes and that's all they are
people I'll return capital to the
shareholders they don't do that they
don't return capital just buy a pizza
with that capital try to do that with
that capital right they take assets and
their balance sheet that have a return
and buy a shares which have a return and
if you've got if you got a company
that's got a ten percent return and you
take assets have a 5% return it's a good
buy
but if your assets return to five and
your company's like the on the triple Q
when you gotta get a p/e of one a p/e of
a hundred excuse me ninety it's actually
the number you're returning one percent
on your company and so so share buybacks
have turned into a reach for yield so by
following these idiots
driving yields solo it meant that assets
on the balance sheet sir from no purpose
back in the 70s and 80s companies loved
assets on the balance sheet because they
would they could get fantastic race rain
so so Powell Powell green from the whole
enchilada they took out that model so
what it did is it bad incentive the
incentive for the companies was to
minimize the cash on their balance sheet
and to maximize the debt which they
could get dirt cheap and buy their
shares and pump them up and get their
options the whole thing has been a
complete Madoff scheme now I understand
the theory of share buybacks and how
they can be good it's just no one's
doing them right and so it's some plan
yeah I understand the theory of sex but
we're talking about a prostitute we're
talking about brothels we're talking
right it's just the wrong what would you
change about the way that they're done
to basically get the positive aspects of
share buybacks captured and get rid of
all of the negative aspects from the
debt and things like that well I'm a
free market guy so engineering anything
doesn't sit right with me
I'd hang the CEOs from the nearest
bridge by their ankles like Mussolini
but couple of most of them left Muslim
dirty lies if the system wasn't so
deeply corrupted then what I would do is
I would never let a CEO be chairman of
the board I wouldn't let him load up the
board with his friends I wouldn't let
them I wouldn't let them swap chair
positions with each other I would if you
really wanted it sent upon here here's a
scheme no one's ever come up with this
one before I said you yeah you have a
cattle call for CEO you would get big
company you get all sorts of people
apply it right you say you're gonna run
the company for three years for free if
you do a real good job according to
these valid metrics that share price up
this you know you know cash flow you
know growth in the business you guys
know how to measure these things then
you get the job and we'll pay you this
right so you give them some in five
years I don't know but you let them work
for five years for
as an assistant CEO and or or you say
you hire real CEO and you say here's
your shares you get shares in this
company you can't cash them in you can't
you can't hedge right there right Akashi
no head you can't get for 10 or 15 years
build us a goddamn company that you know
15 years from now we'll pay you
handsomely for your efforts right and
that's what shareholders should do now I
want time had a chat with Bogle the
argument I made to Bogle as I said you
know indexing means that there's no
adult supervision so in the old days
when IBM had a defined benefits plan IBM
had a vested interest of their the guys
managing that plan to stick their noses
in the GE assay Jack Welch sure cooking
the books right but instead we went to
this defined contribution plan which I
get but now there's no adult supervision
I got the ETF's and you got the you got
the indexing of something so there's no
person that isn't you know maybe they
had a CalPERS or something maybe cares
to stick their noses and say you crooks
shouldn't be given the CEO so much
goddamn money and so many options we're
gonna sell your shares the only guy like
that is Buffett right you gotta the
occasional Buffett who might say to a
seat to a company I'm selling my shares
publicly if you don't change right he
could do it he can be an activist
shareholder for the good of becoming I'm
not a Buffett fan either although I
respect his ability to make money forget
he started out as somewhat of an
activist investor ya know he built he
builds wealth in the sense that he put
in him put in good management he
otherwise accumulate wealth so I guess
part of this is what do you thing about
the by the bailouts right so what I
think I threw a grenade into into
Twitter one day when I said you want to
stop all the bailout nonsense literally
just create a rule that if you're the
CEO of a company that gets bailed out
you can't operate a publicly traded
company for 10 years oh absolutely
like that you know the problem is though
I also don't like the idea of getting in
there and so I think he's the Badger
model where if you're gonna lend money
to companies you charge them a punitive
rate and and so here's a great example
so Carnival Cruise Lines and the various
Cruise Lines are the epitome of the
ballets disaster now I don't think the
boughs have been as bad as they they
looked like they were gonna be but
they're not done yet so I think the real
serious graft is being hidden and
because you know they say well look at
how much money we gave to Joe Sixpack
thing and I get 12,000 I heard this it's
worth gonna get 12,000 dollars a piece
and there's this many of them and you do
the math you know that's not six
trillion hours dude
somewhere out there lurking is a lot of
Giveaways so what happened with carnival
will Carnival besides being a cereal buy
back or I'm dead all the crap they do
they're domiciled in the Caymans and so
they don't pay tax it isn't my point
eight percent taxes when one of their
cruise ships it's the rocks we pay the
cost to go yank him off the rocks and
save them and stuff so it's just a
disaster the average pay supposedly I
haven't documented this but it seemed
like incredible service the average pay
because they're going to the third world
and hiring these guys who can barely
speak English to work on the ship the
average pace on like 250 an hour and
they have to sign up for you know 14
hour days six day weeks it's just and if
one of them gets sick they drop him in a
port and leave them that's it
so Carnival is an insidious program now
what happened well so they obviously
they they were going to be excluded from
the bailouts but something happens so so
Jay Paul announces his bailout program
in what what was happening at the time
was a bunch of hedge funds had gotten
together as a consortium and said we
will lend you money at 15% now these
guys are swashbuckling highway robbers -
but that's the going rate right that's
what happens when you that's the Badgett
model and then all of a sudden what
happen is
j-mo shows up and all of a sudden
they're left at the altar now I don't
have a lot of sympathy for the hedges
who were that good you know the singers
who can really you know rape and pillage
pretty well but but that's intervening
in the market forces and and all of a
sudden next thing they know carnivals
not interested and also next thing they
know they're getting money out of the
banks and way way lower interest rates
so did they bail out carnival directly I
don't know
but certainly the banks also found it in
their goodwill to give kind of a lots of
loans but I think this is part of the
problem right and a lot of people here
the airlines are gonna go bankrupt right
and they think airlines are gonna stop
flying they think that the cruise ships
are gonna stop all these companies are
gonna you know basically like literally
evaporate all the jobs go away etc and
all I continue to hammer on it sounds
like you're in the same bucket here is
there's an equity and a debt market that
market is made when the buyer and the
seller in the market agree on price the
problem is that the airlines the
carnival cruises all these people think
that their company's worth something
that it's not and they're running to the
government because the government's the
idiot in the room the government
literally if you look at the airline
bailouts like 66 percent of the money
that they gave in the bailout is a grant
I don't know what's in my brain around
this you're saying the government's dumb
money I have to think about that yeah
you know a great example this by the way
I've been thinking about this one and I
really so let's go back to one that
really looked like carnage for job loss
that's Arthur Andersen right so they
they can obliterate it but then you sit
back and you put your feet up and you
ponder and you realizes that the demand
for accountants did that drop at all
there were I add what by 30,000
accountants and that for so I don't know
I'm just guessing and and and the
business that they were doing dissipated
to other firms and those guys went off
and worked at the other firms and and so
my brother was arguing what a criminal
thing it was to blow Arthur Andersen out
of the water and I said they committed
so many crimes and then you gotta do it
you gotta blow them out of the water now
if if Moe gets blown out of the
water almost literally someone will buy
up the ships and run the operation
better and quit you know taking on debt
to do buybacks and stuff like that well
but the thing is just being the investor
your point of somebody was gonna give
them dead at 15% and then all of a
sudden the government swoops in right in
all of these different markets and if
you look at you know United Southwest
all these companies they're literally
two-thirds of the money that they were
given was a grant the government got
nothing in return and that's a giveaway
to people who I would like to hang from
the neck until then and and that's the
problem I've had with it now another
role here
remember when Greece went down the tubes
right so this drives me crazy so you I
can remember years ago when Bush was
president some we'd sent thirty billion
dollars to Brazil to bailout Brazil and
it clicked and I was a total neophyte as
opposed to now a fractional me if I and
I thought you know that money's never
gonna get to Brazil let's go straight to
the banks and so we're giving Brazil the
money which by the way won't make it and
they'll be given to our banks or just
bailing out the idiots who loaned Brazil
money right just like you know 100-year
you know Argentinian bonds right how
long did that they take the default what
about six months so so these bailouts
are always just to bail out the big
money and and I'm a capitalist so this
is not this is not Bernie Sanders
ranting about the big guys I'm a big fan
of the big guys who create wealth we got
a happy guys I want some who can create
incredible wealth I do get a little
nervous about the monopolies did you get
big but usually monopoly is protected by
government so if you find a big monopoly
if you dig under the surface you'll find
that they are using the machinery of
government to maintain their their their
vice-grip and so so in any event I yeah
I think it's awful that that these guys
are getting bailed out so so Greece
Greece goes down the tubes right Greece
should have done what Iceland did so
Iceland said screw you we're not paying
we admit that we let fishermen become
bankers and that wasn't the smartest
move we're not paying and I remember the
European bankers were upset about this
but but it was the right thing to do
they just defaulted Greece didn't
default Greece handed over all its
assets you go why why would why would
Greece hand over its assets and the
answer is because one or two or a small
handful of key people in Greece who have
the authority to make the call
got bribed now I don't know if they got
bribed but I'm sitting there and I'm the
head of Greece it's going down the tubes
and stuff like that and someone comes
like says by the way some guy from the
BIS or something says you sign off here
we'll give you ten million in the K
manner what's up Mong SEC of freckie the
Panama papers account and and you hand
over all the goods you'll come out fine
and we know you're a dirtball so you'll
do it or will whack you few doubt all
right we'll do a Clinton approach and
and and so so they just hand it over
right the Greek people didn't hand it
over the Greek authorities handed them
when Germany attacked Czechoslovakia in
1939 the BIS got a request from
Czechoslovakia to transfer all the Czech
gold to Germany and they did it
the BIS said the papers were in order
they did it they got a lot of guff for
it but they were saying we are not a
political organization they said some
gold we send the gold off to German he
went right so breath what they did with
the Greeks they said the Greek heads of
whatever the guys in power sent all
Greeks access to the European banks
so speaking of authorities what how does
this change when you get to bailing out
the state and local governments like
that they're notoriously bad that's an
awful problem because it's always do it
for the children right metaphor do it
for the children well
do it for the the pensioners the problem
I have with that is this that I I hate
the fact that we're bailing out states
that acted so recklessly and
irresponsibly for so many years and so
my brain kind of cramps over the moral
hazard problem there because because if
there was a way I could get to the
people who were reckless again off the
bridge by their ankles off they go right
Mussolini time but there's nobody get to
and so it's that debt has the name is
called odious debt odious debt is debt
that was brought on by by an authority
in which it was so odious so it was done
usually it's a head of some sort of
government head then it is considered
invalid right so that the states have a
pile of this odious debt and and the
promise who how do we make the people
whole then the promise again place like
California they got fire firemen who
were getting two hundred thousand a year
pensions I I don't feel like I should
have to make them whole right I don't
like that I'm making it work I'm paying
a ton of taxes New York State I do not
need to pay you know my proxy Illinois
or or California state taxes to to bail
them out and so I I don't I don't have a
good solution there we screwed up badly
there and I just don't it's it's one of
these like you have stage four cancer
what do you do and the answer is you die
yeah who so what happens in that
scenario breaks I think that that is
part of the analysis is if you let an
illinois let a california just go
bankrupt right you just say look you
screwed up you took risk and now it's
time to pay the piper what happens in
that scenario but who's the you that
screwed up right that that gets back so
so you know there's so many people in
illinois who themselves are guilty of
nothing so they screwed up by electing
idiots well we've all done that so i
just don't i don't have a good answer to
that and at the same time I find it so
repugnant to also have to bail them
and so and so I know I'm good answer I
don't mind dissolving a company right I
don't mind says shareholders are you own
those shares you know you the guys who
thought Jack Welch was God and GE they
eventually ate it they eventually got
what they deserve because they were they
were ignoring the data that was showing
that Welch was massaging his earnings
quarter after quarter for decades and
and they didn't they just that's the
risk of being a shareholder right it's
like a owning you know Philip Morris and
being shocked when you find out that
they get sued for for causing cancer
right now I made a fortune on Philip
Morris betting that they wouldn't hurt
him but that's what if the Fed is gonna
just print and print and print and
they're gonna divert the money to
everyone from the airlines to the states
to you and I may get bailed out and not
even having an excuse for why we got
bailed out does the national debt matter
anymore
like is it even debt if they'll never
pay it back well this gets us back to
your your conversation with Colin I have
come the conclusion people don't
understand inflation I do believe so
when people Colin I would love to have
had a threesome with you guys I know it
sounds weird but I would have because
there's things I thought I would like to
brought up to him and he might even
watch this call or something but there
the national debt will continue to grow
is he sad and people's deaths growl with
GDP in it so he's kind of nonchalant
about that no way am I gonna criticize
call him because he I think he's really
smart but uh but there but the debts are
growing relative to something they
should track so normalized to GDP
normalized to various things they're
growing right and that just doesn't work
and dollar values who cares but in in in
something where the denominator should
erase the the debasement of the currency
part of the problem then
then then when you're growing your debt
you know as a percentage of your GDP
over many many years you are asking for
trouble and and then there's the use
call pollyannas Poly's where they're
short short hand who say well yeah but
we're the reserve currency for now right
you don't get to keep reserve currency
status if you act like idiots so at some
point demographics are gonna kill us
we're gonna the boomers are all gonna be
demanding money the you know Millennials
can't buy the houses the boomers want to
liquidate catastrophic mess coming right
we're on this the other night on Twitter
right
the average McMansion not only is way
over designed for a family right so I'm
like 3.8 people per household and a
McMansion but but they're made like crap
they're not solid I lived in a front
house that was solid and I happen to own
one of these things that's not made very
well he knows made out of supposedly of
materials but but but the cost of
keeping it up so I could theory hand my
house over to my kids they couldn't
afford to keep it because they couldn't
afford my taxes or 25k a year in New
York and I think of housings cheap if
this house was and this house was in San
Diego would be a 30 million dollar house
I mean it's just an extraordinary house
and and I'm replacing windows that are
30 years old and skylights that are 30
years old and roofs and stuff and and
it's you know
hey you it costs a lot of money you
don't a big house and and and so the
millennials the the next generation
doesn't have that kind of money there
are people who do but the bell curve is
not looking very good there's an awful
lot of people who are having trouble
really getting their careers going and
employers are not under pressure to pay
a big bucks you know so you know if your
surgeon you're fine if you're a you know
if your Wall Street you're probably fine
yeah so I don't think the next
generation you buy out the previous
generation
that's the key so let's talk a little
bit about the Federal Reserve in terms
of they're taking all kinds of drastic
actions as you said earlier they've
pumped stock prices back up and and you
don't think that that rally will last
but just how do you think about the
actions they've taken and should they
have done something differently or do
they have another option even though we
don't like what they've done you know
there's a million metaphors out there
now some of which were one point were
original the feds actions have not been
particularly good in my opinion since
greenspan since greenspan started so you
know greenspan to bailout the 87 crash
and in retrospect i think it looks kind
of stupid i think that crash should have
been assert about yeah wake up you can't
just pump markets and then and then and
you know did he actually do anything
that would save it besides some
psychological ploy probably not and and
he pretended to be you know highly
conservative but every time there's a
crisis he jumped in i don't criticize
him for the LTCM bailout bailout because
it wasn't him he got the players
together and said you guys got to write
some checks again the friendly goldman I
said what's gonna stop you guys from
screwing up again and he said nothing
and so Greenspan reached a point where
he started to believe his own presage
and he got very narcissistic he he
really did start to believe he was God
and so so he went out on a high and he
engineered it and we had a lot of room
because we we came from interest rates
of 16% down he got to ride that way if
you got to ride the greatest bull market
bombs in the 20th century and and that
makes him look real good so then
Bernanke takes over and Bernanke got
handed a loser and he's an academic so
he had all these theoretical approaches
to his credit he he went further outside
the box and I think anyone could
possibly
outside the box I don't think Bernanke's
public presentations of what happened in
the depression are correct I don't know
whether whether he doesn't understand as
I as I understand it or whether he just
is willing to lie I think it must be the
latter but he blames he blames fed
actions in the 30s that caused the
depression and in my opinion was very
clearly fed mistakes in the 20s it
caused the depression it might have been
fed action in the 30s that failed to
save the day
but you all you need to do you want it
you want to know how you want to see the
boom-bust cycle the best boom by cycle
you ever see boot up a plot of the Dow
from 1900 to 1940 and what you'll see is
you'll see the boom-bust cycle it goes
up and then it comes down and then
recovers you can draw a line right
through the boom and the bust and it's
this beautiful sort of slow methodical
dependence and and I gotta get my phone
to stop ringing and so Bernanke claims
was the 30s it was the 20s there was all
sorts of they they lowered
they lured reserve requirements they
lowered interest rates they they were
trapped one of the claims is they're
trying to get gold to shove back to
England after World War one and stuff
like that but they they blew a gigantic
bubble it wasn't just inequity Pablo sir
it was a credit bubble it was a consumer
credit bubble so so the the the
depression was a beautiful example of a
purging of the excesses of the 20s the
roaring 20s so Green Bernanke professes
not to understand that in my opinion and
same with Friedman for that matter I had
these guys I think they swirl their own
kool-aid they drink their own piss and
Volcker is a hero but I don't view them
as so altruistic I think Volcker
recognized what the system needed so so
all these guys aren't charged with
making sure the banks are fine right
that's it said the banks hold all the
money they make all the money they
create all the money they run the world
there's there's no alternative model
that makes sense to me right you can
have
since the countries they don't care they
will pick the president if they have to
write as as as who's it said that ah
Dudley last year said that if we have to
we worry about who's president but so
Volker recognized that what the system
mean it was a perch
so when Volker hiked up the interest
rates to put a lid on inflation
expectations and I've had central
bankers telling me that that cost
inflation and I've been trying to wrap
my brain around that one but then what
happened he started to bring him back
down again and in any heat sir
apparently sat the big bankers down and
said you guys got to behave yourself
we're out of control here and the
bankers didn't listen to him and so he
jammed him back up again and and so he
had to show the banking system that he
was dead serious and that seemed to
break the fever
so then Volker set the stage for Greece
but never party so then you go past when
we jump back to Bernanke and he gets
credit for saving the world
he saved the world from a raging inferno
that was the creation of the Fed in my
opinion so at some point it's like
giving him credit for stopped beating
his wife
I don't it's you know the arsonist
firemen fighter you know firefighter
combo it the crack [ __ ] who keeps
getting crack and it's at some point you
have to purge the system Volcker
recognizes the last one they recognize
that and every since ever since then
we've had fed chairs who were who were
basically saying not in my watch just
not on my watch so Yellen sat there
treading water best I could ask you did
a squat
you know she started hiking race from
what zero and so she was just following
Bernanke's queue I don't think she knew
anything long comes Powell who look like
maybe he gets it then all of a sudden
you know the markets drop eighteen
percent or something and and men who
couldn't Powell you know establish the
PowerPoint was also you know it's
trouble
leverage loan markets so they were
actually more worried about that but the
bottom line is that they're never
willing to let someone projectile vomit
they're just never one to let to sit and
say sorry guys you screwed the pooch the
CEO screwed the pooch now we gotta live
with it they and therefore now we have
bigger and bigger problems so I blame
them and the fact that there's an even
bigger problem kovin was unanticipated
but we'd be a lot better off if we
didn't go into it with the world's
biggest historically biggest corporate
credit bubble of all time and so if you
look at the bailouts buried in there
that six trillion dollars is a lot of
money to deal with corporate credit and
if there wasn't a corporate credit
bubble that wouldn't have to exist who's
holding all the corporate Corbin right
it's the pension money that's the
problem right but also what's also what
does that do so what it does it gives
people a false sense of wealth so if if
if you bruh Steve you're rich and I
don't really want to go here but let's
say you've got a gazillion now for the
Bitcoin it alters your thinking so so
I'm sure you want a lot of Bitcoin
there's no way you don't know a lot of
Bitcoin the perception of wealth alters
your thinking of Bitcoin is legit it's a
legitimate altering of your thinking if
Bitcoin turns out to be what its
detractors think it is then then you
have made personal decisions that were
monstrously bad probably now once you
get a bunch of money it's really hard to
not drop your guard it's really hard to
not say well you know I can afford that
boat now I can't afford a bigger house
now and and so the boomers are all being
handed these inflated assets now they
said you know at one point they thought
they'd never return honest and you know
now I can afford to retire well watch
you retire they're gonna throw a toaster
oven in the pool you are going to die
and so so so it's the it's the false
Reid that everyone's being given by the
perception that the corporate debt
problem is
the problem it is a problem and and you
can have a global debt problem it is a
problem and if you want to know how to
create a global debt problem let's let's
do a Gedanken experiment let's say every
country they get together at Davos they
say you know what we just should give
everyone free health care just everyone
just everyone by the way we should
promise all the retirements and
everything they'll walk out of there
everyone will perceive they're stinking
rich now and they will have done nothing
to improve our ability to create wealth
not one shred of what they just decided
increases our ability to create wealth
therefore that's a global debt problem
yeah you mentioned earlier this this
idea that the global reserve currency
only gets to be the global reserve
currency if you're not an idiot about it
basically you also are a big proponent
of gold precious metals you've done very
well on those in the past and then you
mentioned Bitcoin how do you see these
three things kind of colliding and how
does this play out moving forward like
do you see the dollars of global reserve
currency does gold have a place as a
global currency or store of wealth and
then what do you think about Bitcoin and
all of that
I don't think Gold's ever going away
it's been around for five thousand years
there there's there's there's memes
about gold that I don't buy and there's
memes about gold that I do and I think
the 5,000 year histories are real right
so I don't think if we ever get to the
point where gold this perceives is not
worth anything I'm buying much much more
but it never will get there and in fact
I think central bankers value it that
they don't want us to value it they want
us to value their currencies but but
when you know when Greensboro's asked
why don't you sell your gold then by ron
paul actually he said no and so everyone
knows the gold is like this bedrock that
you do not want to pull out from
underneath and that's why you know and
then as a whale or something goes down
the first thing we do is we we said you
know we send airplanes in there to pick
up the gold and take it back to Europe
again or the United States the whether
it's good or not it's a separate
question because if if twenty years from
now I can buy less with an ounce of gold
when I combine now then it was probably
not a very good thing to have but it
won't I don't think it'll go to zero
Bitcoin is a is a great experiment I'm
not a believer in it but I'm some level
I'm rooting for you guys I figure
Bitcoin goes nuts gold little - so you
and I can you know buy entire apartment
complexes together and start a new
venture capital system here so I I have
no trouble imagining that Bitcoin goes
completely down the tubes
that's and I've never been able to
convince myself that it was that that
was not one of the risks I also think
that the that it could survive and do
well there's varying opinions about how
what it has to become to survive and
thrive and I've gotten different
opinions from different people if it has
to become a real currency it's got to
settle down right you can't wake up and
find groceries cost ten percent more
today because of Bitcoin that's why it
by the way why I don't consider gold
money or should I say your currency I
don't like getting into the Gold Bug
discussion my goal being real money cuz
I go you know if called tanks things
cost more right and you say if the
dollar tanks I go yeah but it doesn't
act that fast so if I wanted to know
that something was going to cost the
same six months from now I would hold
the dollar knuckle and I would not hold
Bitcoin either and so I think it has to
settle down so I think Bitcoin of some
points gotta flush the speculators out
it's got to become boring and it has to
survive sovereign states going at it and
I know you've heard this a million times
I know your listeners right you're
you've got
knowing your name your company write
this it's a it's a subsidiary of Morgan
Creek or you just yarn Creek yes
city oh yeah right that's a mouthful did
you were you into Bitcoin and you tied
up with usko or or were you with usko
and and you sort of spun off a Bitcoin
subsidiary the the former okay there was
going on we're doing a bunch of mining
and the general thought process so
here's a question for you on this so
Gary Cohen right who is somewhat
controversial in finance versus crypto
but yes so he's got a view that a
cryptocurrency is likely to become a
major global currency but it won't be
Bitcoin Jim Bianco a cryptocurrency will
be the next global reserve currency it
won't be Bitcoin are they saying that it
will be a sovereign crypto so that's
part of the discussion right is if you
asked Jim I don't know what he would
actually say does he think it'll be
that's not a crypto though okay
so right you had to pick in the future
is the next global reserve currency
backed by a state whether it's digital
or not or not asking question or do you
buy into the argument that there can be
separation of state and money in the
next global reserve currency will just
be a separation whether it's Bitcoin or
something else well I think the
separation of currency and sovereigns
will be over the dead bodies of a lot of
sovereign leaders and and the bankers
and and since I just made the case
before that the guys who make the money
and home the money run the world that
you're asking are they going to lose
control of the world and that's so
you're up against some pretty tough
hombres and my biggest concern about
Bitcoin would be is that in a world it
is it appears to be getting increasingly
oppressive within the democrat
democratic societies right so we've all
wanted outs and democracy and next thing
you know you look at me
I'm not sensing the democracy that I use
you know you look at the 2016 election
you know Bert you know Hillary didn't
really beat Bernie you know she kind of
just mowed his ass down and then you
look at the Russia clues and you go god
they were trying to take Trump out at
the kneecaps so you get a sense that
that the democracy is strong going a
little bit here right now we're not
we're not getting to vote for things as
much as we think it is hard for me to
picture that in that world that if you
outlaw crypto that the average person
will say screw you I'm still using it
and if you don't get the average person
it becomes up it becomes a sort of an
off-off-broadway currency and and then
it might have a role but it certainly
isn't
that's not your home run that's not your
home run yeah so I agree with that the
one caveat to it is let's say the US
right if you kind of go through the game
theory the u.s. says you want we're
gonna ban ownership of Bitcoin so if
you're a US citizen you hold this you're
in breach of the law and we're gonna
throw you in jail we're gonna find you
we're gonna confiscate it we're gonna do
whatever does that open an opportunity
for Russia China and other superpowers
to say wait a second we want to get off
that u.s. dollar system it's super
expensive there's tons of control of the
US has if they are going to ban
ownership of this we should actually
adopt this together as kind of a rest of
the world I gotta say I haven't thought
about that but the problem is they don't
want to give up the sovereign control of
it either so it gets back to would that
be a crypto and then of course you get
the you get the real nightmare scenario
of Mark Zuckerberg running you know
Libre or was it Libre Libre the other
problem with with the cryptos right now
is there's what 5,000 of them it reminds
me of the car dealerships nowhere near
the numbers but the car dealerships in
the 20s there were some like 250 of them
are thirty of them or something like
that most were going to die
right so the question is how do you know
and then that comes right how do you
know which doctrine was going to that my
friend Goldman he was the founder of AB
Goldman software group
now that's that's foundation level right
that's really amazing and he was there
when Microsoft was taking public Andales
and and I answer I said it was Microsoft
always an obvious winner he said no no
no no not even close he said there were
a number of occasions where you could
easily imagine going to zero and so is
by no means a lock it's really easy to
see a company is a lock after the fact
I'm gonna give you a framework that I
use to think about all the different
kryptos again no promise that this is
accurate but it's just what I've tried
way into but it's the idea that when we
look at companies let's say in the
dot-com we always think about revenue
technology kind of your moat you know
all of those different things it's very
much a what did you build type defense
in order to be a survivor
money's a little different and actually
what I think is money is a belief system
right that's why people believe gold has
value they believe dollar has value and
so in some weird world I've convinced
myself that we get one shot at the
separation of state and money if it
doesn't work with Bitcoin people
basically will never believe in the
second third fourth like if you gotta
shoot at the King you better kill some
degree right because ultimately what you
get is you know it's kind of like if
you're in Venezuela right and all of a
sudden your currency fails the
government shows up it goes oh just
kidding that one didn't work but like
here's our next one yeah I'm good right
yes I don't know look it's a it's
fascinating I probably shouldn't say who
it is but somebody in the financial
media who's very well-known said to me
it's the one asset that he could bring
ten of the smartest people in finance he
knows into a room ask them what they
thought walk out when he comes back five
will be on one side of the room five
will be the other and they'll literally
think the other five are complete idiots
right right where I would say they're
all probably idiots oh so I want to talk
a little bit about politics real quick
you mentioned Trump and all that kind of
stuff
what is your general outlook right now
in terms of Biden V Trump coming up in
November I don't think that's what the
pairing will be I think Biden nobody
take a note who do you think replaces
them I think that port now I think all
the data points to that so so when when
if you looked at Republican primaries
over the last number of elections the
the putative former presumed nominee you
could pick him out in the primaries and
what I notice is like when Romney was
most nominated all these guys were on
stage and now these are all carefully
orchestrated all their handlers say no
no unfair this their watch and this is
like a faceoff in La Crosse right how do
you keep it from getting dirty and and
at the same time in that Romney was in
the middle that tells you the first hit
second thing his suit was slightly
different color and I'm going there's no
way that they let one of the guys have a
different color suit but right there in
the middle went blank my lord a blue
right there in the middle I go holy crap
they're grown your eye right to Romney
in what Bush got nah man wasn't even a
choice right and then I saw it again
with Jabba and and what happened with
Jeb though is is that no one saw Trump
coming in jab showed an unbelievable
inability to handle Trump so no one saw
the glass jaw
it was going to be a Clinton Bush
president brawn right it was really
straightforward and so um so so we're
not getting to pick him I'm not sure I
can remember what your question was
ah v Cuomo yeah so so what do you see
now well first of all buying is not in
sight Trump's I would say the the
covered problem has been his biggest
challenge because because spontaneous
utterances don't work well at all he's a
fighter he's a brawler he's a bully and
this doesn't lend itself
so I'd say hey Lapointe then he started
to look like he got his legs on the
ground for a while and next thing you
know you know the media's still able to
turn him into an idiot again with you
know Lysol in the veins and stuff like
that and and I think we're gonna find
that some of the stuff he said earlier I
was gonna look pretty intelligent that
he got massacred on you know like where
I'm desappear or something you know and
and him that the media's killing him on
taking hydrochloric wine and stuff like
that you know we might find that's the
one so I don't know but um what were
watching is Biden Biden should have been
beating the tar out of him there's no
chance that if Hillary was running
against Trump that she wouldn't be on
every Sunday talk show and her Ken meant
pain management every talk show and her
handlers on every talk show and they
would be going to them day and day and
CNN would be all over it and there is
not a sign abide he is you know
breakfast at Bernie's he's he sit and
propped up like a corpse with his
sunglasses on right and they don't he's
not even out there defending his
candidacy and for all I know he's not
lost his marbles although it sure looks
like he has so I gotta figure they're
hatching a plan to get him out of there
it could involve bringing was a Tara
Reid and it could involve couldn't Bob
for all we know the Democrats were
releasing all the Biden garble videos
right and at some point they'll do
something like I don't even understand
it won't call it a brokered convention
I'll pretend like I know what that is
and and now there'll be a recruit Cuomo
cuz they're not going to burn me really
gonna go Kamala Harris right they're
gonna go after Elizabeth Warren they're
nowhere in sight so there's no evidence
of anyone but Cuomo and he's on every
day New York could be you know a killing
field he'd be on every day and star I
think it's qualms on he just babbles
coherently and it doesn't freak me
because I don't want Bernie as president
I hated Hillary with a passion
Obama was fine I didn't care about Obama
you know I don't know why people hated
Obama
I understand might not like his politics
but that's separate I'd the guy I
thought was very impressive in his own
way and-and-and-and Cuomo look at he's
kind of old-school he's got skeletons in
the closet he was involved various
things having to do you'd call graph but
oh my god knows ever done that before
and and you could imagine a Trump Cuomo
battle being a pretty fair octagon fight
right do you think wins that well it a
lot will depend on what where it goes
from here I mean Trump Trump's stock and
go up and down like Bitcoin right and
and so Trump could totally shoot himself
in the foot uh if if this whole thing
rallies then Trump Trump I think would
win and if he could easily blow in Cuomo
wins I wouldn't be freaked by Cuomo
president that would bottom you know I
feel like he is a candidate exactly what
you're talking about the other side
isn't completely scared of him and
therefore says hey I may not agree with
the politics hey I mean I think that
he's that you know the best candidate
but I would be ok with it it's less kind
of push back the one thing I keep going
back to though is it just feels like the
political landscape has changed and and
the one you know you just read happened
again recently where Trump is willing to
do things that other people don't
understand yet right so when he's
literally posting the the memes and the
videos the doctored video of him as the
president and Independence Day right and
he's saying you know the invaders are
coming but I will save you or you know
whatever the hell the thing is and it's
his face superimposed he's just wanting
to go to a level where you know
Bloomberg tried to do this well Boomer
basically was paying people to you know
they put pictures on Instagram it's not
authentic he was awful it reminded
Bloomberg be bright I reminded me the
Republicans trying to sell various
candidates hoping that one of them would
get lags and every week we'd find out
some candidate was doing really great
they'd be gone within a week so yes I
think Trump is is so capricious there's
a great
article or interview I can't remember
what it was for someone who was maybe
there's a ban an interview where he
talked about when he lined up the
Clinton rape victims right before the
presidential debate and I thought that
was just genius I'm thinking holy crap
that is like you know you might as well
take fraid I would shoot him out in the
boat right that's serious stuff I by the
way I I had a bigger effect on the
presidential cried to influence
presidential campaigns really funny
sighs I'm Ron Paul's homepages an
endorser that didn't seem to play out as
well as I would have hoped and that was
a no way and then and then wanita
Broderick shows up on Twitter and she
she says something like Hillary bill you
know you raped me and Hillary you know
you tried to destroy me and nobody was
there now there's just the trouble is
that heard some some media guy said I
made a few phone calls that's her so I
taught her how to pin a tweet and she
pinned that tweet and it went bananas
right so I got screen grabs someone will
doesn't believe me I can show you the
screen refresh it she said thanks Dave I
did it I use that my annual survey where
I showed that I said this this is high
influence an election you teach one need
a broader kind of pin tweets right I'm
gonna predict a future president well
when you own a future thirty years from
now who savant Aymeric who's that the
mayor of Ithaca really fine a Merrick
was the youngest mayor in the country he
was something like 26 years old he's
funny he's articulate he's very Obama
he's light-skinned african-american you
know reason I say this cuz she's still
got a bunch of Bubba's out there on a
vote for real black guys right it's
appalling as that seems you know that's
true and he's he's he's Cornel
educated when he was a kid there was a
period when he and his mother and the
family were homeless he has the story
he's I've had conversations with him I'm
impressed by the guy and I asked him his
hem national politicians shown any real
interest yet he says no I'm not trying
to believe it I think that might be a
cancer he was on Meet the Press he was
on CNBC the other day and so I think
this guy is he's so much better than the
Democratic candidates were seeing I put
him up now instead of these clowns right
anyone can be beat oh I'd take out beat
oh but uh but so this guy's gonna be
good and and so I said that a Twitter I
said this guy someone said what's the
mayor during spring break or something
and I said something very favorable and
I got followed by a woman named I think
you're his name was Leslie Merrick and
I'm gone
that's gotta be mom buying favors buying
favors 30 years from now
Savanti Merrick you know mark your
calendars he's gonna he's gonna get he's
gonna at least get to Congress it's good
I uh I always say that the person I
could see running and winning who would
be the wild card is the rock because
he's got three back well he hears he's
got three things ready if we get into a
world where it's literally a popularity
contest he's the most recognized actor
in the world too
he's got the physical stature tons of
studies that show just you know if
you're six six and literally got muscles
to your ears right usually look like you
should be the leader and then three is
he's just enough intelligent and just
enough charismatic where you can imagine
you know him going up against let's say
somebody like a trump who's a bully he's
standing up there and Trump you know
kind of comes at him and he literally
goes ha ha and puts his hand on her
shorten go shut your candy ass up right
just just kind of just just very much
can can diffuse those situations which
actually you know if you read like a
scott adams book
you know how he looked at drop like
that's sort of trou Scott Adams and
analyses of Trumper from now on aren't
they you know he he tears it right down
to the studs when he analyzes trumpeted
I think it drives trumpeters crazy
because he does a wonderful job Scott
Adams as amazingly he gets he King a
pretty wackadoodle I mean he can really
go outside the box but his analysis of
Trump and how how how good he is at and
I think he I think he said he was a good
convinced ur or or say he's some word
like that and and he he discourse we she
uses English language to his credit most
people think he can't speak English and
they don't realize her getting duped he
uses a weapons-grade persuasion I think
is Adams predicted Trump way in advance
I saw Trump coming so I watched him in
it I wrote a an analysis of the election
that worked out really well in part
because I paid I gave Trump more credit
early on that most people would so he
wasn't just a novelty so I started
watching and you know I take all these
notes and shouldn't keep track of links
and so when when he finally won us sort
of poison uh I know I won know and
mostly there were mistakes made by
Hillary mostly there were mistakes
she's there a couple of fatal fatal
mistakes she made you know they seem at
some level trivial but I don't think
they were and so yeah it was fun
watching that election I gotta confess I
I'm not a big Trump fan I'm Trump
tolerant but I love the disruption I
love the fact that he went against two
parties simultaneously in one my my
whole take away from the last really
five years right including the the
election running up to it and him as
president is uh he has done more
positive damage to politics then we
probably understand right now meaning
that he basically walked in threw a
grenade in the room and
and said I don't care which party it
hits right I'm basically gonna just
disrupt this whole thing and it will
change the way that campaigns are run
that politicians you know think about
their communication strategies all that
stuff he described the SUBSCRIBE when he
finally realized what Trump was made of
he Trump made one of his first big
apparent blunders and Lewandowski starts
talking to him saying well we're gonna
do this and this and this to repair this
and Trump said screw that and ludo see
that's when I realized that he was not
your normal candidate yeah and and look
part of it is you know the the thing
that you have to be intellectually
honest about right is the guy says dumb
stuff all the time he shoots himself in
the foot every day and it's almost like
he's got thicker skin right than
everybody hurts assist narcissist I've
ever seen
what is he I but he's a narcissist but
he doesn't care what is that right and
and and then here's that here's the
shock though so the shock was is that
Trump sent this fantastic warning shot
across the bow of the two parties to
straighten up in the first example we
got the first evidence we got is the
Democrats and they just completely
screwed the pooch they needed you know
all they had to do is find another Obama
and they couldn't come close to that
right I thought Warren was gonna get it
I thought they were gonna sort of leave
her in the shadows and keep her from
getting bruised up and knocked out and
stuff and then sort of hammered through
a sort of a rally like a Jimmy Carter
thing and and and then she just she
started looking shrill and Clintonesque
and and it just wasn't selling it just
was by the way I used to chat with
Elizabeth Warren late at night and it
was so at that one day I was supporting
her in Twitter and that the Washington
bureau chief of the Guardian says can we
chat I said sure he calls me he says I'm
writing an article
my Elizabeth Warren and what it is that
appeals to people I've noticed that
you've been a supporter so I so I told
my story but I said I'm also supportive
Ron Paul and a blue insert he wrote an
article in The Guardian about my support
for Ron Paul and Elizabeth Warren that
is such a wada bipolarity you cannot you
cannot you know that's holding to ideas
that are in conflict in the same pad I
tell my said I think they're both honest
I'm not sure that's true now but at the
time I thought she was I thought she's
very sincere and that's better than
everyone else
so speaking of honesty mentioned Hillary
Clinton and I listened to your podcast
with with Marty bent which was fantastic
and you gave your your Jeff Epstein
theory what is the what's the latest
thought process on Jeffrey Epstein and
in that entire situation well it really
hasn't changed because it all went away
which is a classic except that the the
classic picture was this guy from the
same as Burge or something on Twitter I
don't even know who he is but he's got a
popular Twitter feed he showed a picture
of the Ark and Raiders of the Lost Ark
being put in the warehouse right the
hopelessly lost ark and he says he says
we won't be needing this anymore
it was the Epstein case and that's
exactly what happened so I'm still
reasonably comfortable with the idea
that he's not dead I think the the
analysis of the corpse coming out in the
building was very good I think I think
the the profiles of the guy coming out
didn't match didn't match I've seen it
all the nose shape the ear shape and
that was pretty good
and on top of that I mean there's a
thing called a suicide switch or
something where you say look get me out
of here alive or I'm releasing the info
and and he had more dirt on the global
elite than anyone and so the question is
you know why would he not have used it
so I think if you find jizz laying
Maxwell what I call jizz for short for
obvious reasons and if you find
if you find her you might find him but
we can't find her either because of
course we're not looking you know we'll
find out Oh Jai's wife's killer before
we find she's Maxwell an Epstein but I
don't think he's dead I think he's in
witness protection so I had some nose
jobs and [ __ ] done so what do you think
he is oh it's big world I don't know you
know I just don't know where she well
that's my point is is this like a remote
island no one can find them where's this
hidden in plain sight plain sight well
you know when when the most famous
powerful people in the world will all
lose their asses if he gets to skub he's
not gonna get discovered right so I have
to do is make him after hack of his face
a bit make it different but that but you
could do that yeah you could you know
look what they do that Hollywood stars
who get face jobs there I'm Mickey
Rourke oh look at Mickey Rourke and tell
me you'd recognize him in a lineup
writer or Caitlyn Jenner right there we
go yeah she's probably a chick I mean
that's a pretty wild theory I think that
I'm just throwing stuff out to explain
put it this one there's more than a 0%
probability that that could be true oh
wait I think it's I'm actually rather
comfortable with the idea and then
they're never you know there's none of
the other guilty parties have ever been
challenged right and and and so the ABS
I'm gonna read one of the Epstein books
I was actually the other day thinking
about finding one in there what you
don't want to do is get one that's a
whitewash so I got to find the right one
I could I think Whitney Webb's is coming
out but but she's kind of I really like
her but there's kind of a skitzy quality
and so she she tends to throw the puzzle
piece on the table and then and doesn't
assemble them all and I kind of like the
fact that she can see the puzzle pieces
but don't know how they fit together
but yeah I think the Epstein
connectivity was so profound and I have
no doubt that he had huge connections
with intelligence that that's that story
is so he
we made and so he's he's in a safe house
or something or a safe island or
whatever and and you know whatever
happened to the Panama papers right
25,000 accounts in the Caymans that
lasted what three days maybe he seems to
go away what happened Corzine right
where is he we do in the crook speaking
of these uh shining light maybe on the
darkness of the world Zero Hedge went
out on the top man right before I mean I
continue to periodically tweet don't
forget zero has Ruby having a literally
a field day right now in last eight
weeks and by the way their tweets on the
kovat are getting are getting these
massive warnings on Twitter when someone
else posts a link someone told me all
their links no they're not they're the
koban links so it's it's it's some
people in authority who want to make
sure that alternative views of the
coated virus are not getting out there
these are not wacky ideas some of them
are remarkably benign and somehow you
put koban zero heads together in the
same the same webpage and it gets a it
gets a warning that says this could have
malware and there's none of that zero
head is way better than the mainstream
press way better
you got a filter right they haven't they
they have some pretty wacky stuff there
but it's lost a lot of stuff that's
showing up there that's I think coming
from powerful people were you know ghost
writing the stories and you know so I I
think I rarely see zero head to look
dead wrong sometimes they seem like they
got it a little off but really dead
wrong I am I continue to think that this
this whole idea of censoring ideas that
don't agree with the institution's is
not only one the dumbest idea I've ever
heard but two is a direct attack on
science it's a direct attack on the
truth simply because it just the köppen
crisis we've seen the institution's been
wrong over and over
over again if you can't question what
those people are saying or you can't
question other types of thought
processes you basically make no progress
well in it so let's take it all the way
the deep state that there it appears as
though you you can make that you can go
very deep in the comb in crisis too and
find theories that you can't refute and
there's a there's a gob of them right
and so something having to do with China
you know whether it's a bioweapon to me
whether to buy weapons not that
interesting because because we all make
bio weapons apparently and one got out
and we blew it and I think I think there
there's some potentially deep
information about what we knew and when
we knew it or or a funny meme the other
day was all about buying this and what
did he know and when did he forget it
and so I there's a lot of stuff and the
koban the dump that don't add up and
they're just the math the math doesn't
add up
why was New York a disaster why why was
LA not it's just not obvious to me I
wouldn't be shocked if the numbers were
being way over counted way under counted
I heard Mexico's way under counting as
you mentioned hospitals have a
tremendous incentive to designate a
Kovan a patient as a Corbett patient so
here's a story for this true stories
happened to me my life is what we've
done to the system this is a great
example actually gonna write about this
one my wife about six years no no no
seven or eight years ago one night did
slipped into the header in the kitchen
and I woke up to her you know started
giving a yell out and I put her to bed
and the next day the next day she slept
all day and you go oh that's kind of a
warning but my wife has tremendous
health problems massive health problems
and so it was within the noise
the next day she calls me she says I
really ought to go get an x-ray so it
turns out we can I take her the hospital
and I said should I call it and she said
now just let's just drive Hospital and
we get there and it turns out you in a
double fraction or neck and partway
there I'm going boy she is awfully
vibration sensitive this is a problem so
it's not a long drive but I'm going this
is creepy and so uh and they missed it
at first and in the dock when she took
the brace off and said there's no brake
you're fine and she sat up and she put
her hand held her headlight with her
hand like that and he put the brace back
and came back and said you had a double
break turns out it was a 40% fatality
probability the break she had now really
weird tangentially my mother did a
header broke her neck and died so they
would have been really where they would
have been stringing me up so in any
event about two weeks ago she was
gardening if she did this a funny play
on words she did a faceplant and we
didn't think much about it besides the
fact that her faced we're picking a
piece of mulch out of her face but then
the next day she is talking about how
much it hurt and I was watching her and
then it dinner she was doing this like a
[ __ ] we're taking in the hospital
tonight and and it seemed much less
traumatic I still put her in a car right
you could say it when are you gonna
learn this we go to the hospital I can't
go in she's terrible at talking about
her health problems cuz she said so
she's at 59 surgeries she doesn't like
to tell anyone that number I want to go
in cuz I want to tell him how
complicated her neck is she's got two
fusions she's got a heel on the brake
that's not that didn't work well and
then they will let me in I pick her up
three hours later after getting a call
say come get your wife and all she got
was that it was negative they did a CT
scan negative she never talked to a
doctor they literally took her into the
CT somewhere out there in
possibly India where they're reading
later night CT scans some guy said
nothing there no way to really transmit
this information the guy and she gets a
negative like it's a pregnancy test and
the next day I call my GP and I said
this is just appalling he got me an
orthopedic we got her and he fiddled
with her jiggle with her and and she did
not have a break but that's what we've
done to our health care system now
here's what's gonna happen our health
care system that's worse private
equity's been buying up hospitals
private equity of course we know does
one of several things one is they they
try to make a lot of money which means
it's probably not gonna be an RS
interest second of all they will
strip-mine the damn thing and load it up
with that and screw that how I think pay
themselves big things and then sell off
the shell and then because it's a shell
and I blame the Fed for that you go how
do you blame the Fed for a private
equity selling shell so the company's
the answer is because there's so much
stupid money out there when money when
capital is precious
people don't buy shells of companies
they do their due diligence
now there's dumb money out there they
buy yeah yeah we'll buy the house or
buying a three a day right and they'll
sell off the shells of the hospitals and
then and now now what's going on well
the hospitals are going bankrupt because
of this koban thing so the PE guys are
coming up and buy him on on fire sale
prices then what we're gonna goddamn do
is if they don't turn them into a shell
and bankrupt them they're gonna milk
profits and we're gonna get national
health care of this to pay the PE guys
it's gonna happen it's gonna happen and
I don't know who I'm gonna string up and
hang off the goddamn bridge for that one
but I'm gonna find if I get liver cancer
there is a list of people who are in a
world of pain your real job your day job
is education how does that change coming
out of all this oh so the question is
what's going on with colleges
I have been on a bit of a crusade to say
we should be graduating half as many
people from colleges we are currently
graduating there are majors that should
be minors they're minors it should be
courses in their courses that should be
history noticed upon their um you cannot
pay a quarter of a million dollars in
major in sociology I just
if this podcast gets to our sociology
chair there's gonna be a [ __ ] session I
don't care you cannot it is an on
extinguish herbal debt a quarter of a
million dollars to major in sociology
and so and at the same time the cost of
college is just soaring or maybe not
going forward and the question is why
what I can tell you is my department is
chemistry runs leaner and meaner than
when I got here less staff per capita
less support for capita and we're pretty
close to the top and so I got a figure
that's general so the question is where
is all the money going and I think it's
a lot of unfunded mandates so when
you're accepting federal dollars you
have to do all sorts of stuff which
includes having themes of diversity
who's having accounting things and all
sorts of you know all sorts of stuff so
colleges are just so much more
complicated than they used to be and
meanwhile you know the cost of dorms and
suffer going up because the kids there's
a there's a an arms race going on so if
if one school's building fancy dorms as
for all the freshmen are gonna go
there's an arms race that's gonna appear
in medical school soon and why you just
just declared free tuition no tuition
for all med students from here on out
last year no tuition now imagine you're
sitting at Columbia's a first-year med
student and often the headline says NYU
has no tuition as of the stain you're
going
I turned down NYU I can't believe I
turned down and right so what's the best
med school in the country right now
and why are you because it's the only
place you go free and so that's going to
then what's gonna happen to that well
what's gonna happen to that then
society's gonna say okay now that you're
not paying a fortune you get to work
cheaper now you get we get to send you
places we get to send you to you know
Sheboygan where we need more doctors
somehow this could be the beginning of
them are social as a socialized medical
care curiously enough so I don't know I
don't know where academia is going but
we're we're way too expensive you should
not be studying English literature with
a 500 English SAT and they're out there
my son went to a four-year college to a
two-year college in the Adirondacks that
offered four majors they were all very
pragmatic was a great program he went to
a four-year college after that to get it
finished a four-year degree not a famous
place but uh he'd studied event
management and now he works for the CFR
so so I think college must be much more
pragmatic and the problem with that is
is there's a lot of majors and stuff out
there that aren't pragmatic you think
that the way the education is delivered
changes right that this is kind of
technically speaking well just there's a
lot of kids sitting at home right now
saying you know hey I'm calling into my
Cornell class and I'm paying all this
money one should I even be in college if
if I'm not going in person and then two
is you know does the cost change if the
experience changes to some degree well
the experience definitely changes right
now we've got a problem with things like
lab courses are a farce right we pretend
to teach them they pretend to learn
that's it
we're laboring up for what to do in lab
courses if we can't open up I just don't
think he can keep playing the game that
a lab course doesn't require going in
the lab we made the emphasize laboratory
right who says freshman chemists have to
go in the lab right you could just learn
chemistry at the labs I remember
thinking pretty badly anyway so you know
who cares I'm not sure a big loss there
I
do you think there's a real social
upheaval when people finally figure out
that you can do something online and
then the question is what is the role of
elite I'm told Harvard Law School now it
takes about four hours to do the work if
someone's from Harvard Law School that
disagrees send me an email I don't care
I'm glad to hear it but I had a student
who went there he said he takes about
four hours to do the work that's not the
Paper Chase which was a famous movie
book years ago it was just cutthroat and
killer now now it's it seems like a
finishing school
if that's true if that's true so you
know business schools are really about
just getting the sheepskin and being
able to say you have an MBA that seems
so wasteful I don't think you should
have to take what is it seven years to
get a law degree this Frank Abagnale II
who was the the famous imposter he
passed the bar without going to college
I think a four-year degree that includes
a major in law that then you take the
bar would be fine
there's a but that meant law schools
right now our cash cows right that
that's where the business school is a
cash cow you know medical schools are
cash cows because they have because they
have clinical treatment facilities so
their hospitals and med schools that's
gliese being ethical but we didn't have
the bodies to work with so you to run a
med school you have to have a lot of
indigent people the thing that I think
is really interesting is there's two
things at play right so one is this
Kovac thing kind of exposed a lot of
shams in society one of them mmediately
becomes hey do I have to go in the
classroom or kind of swatch online if I
can watch online how does that change my
expectation I do think there's a lot of
value to the social experience right
which I think you know some people still
for sure desire and seek out but the
other piece of it is the business of the
school right and so you know one of the
things I've said it's like look a lot of
these schools they've got massive asset
management firms right I mean look these
endowments or
millions and billions of dollars and
part of what I think people are asking
is just does any of that change right
does the way that they allocate capital
changes the way they invest change does
the way that the federal government
interacts with the schools who have
large endowments change like like what
is the impact to the actual business of
the school and I don't think people know
yet right look I know here's the problem
though and that is if you can find a way
that that huge wealth is distorting the
system then you have a case but for
example I'm sitting in a building called
Olin Hall created by the Olin family
which Olin Chemical next doors Baker lab
which is George Fisher Baker who was a
JPMorgan pier to the extent they exist
across the hall across the street is a
building built by Seth Klarman next door
is a building built by john d
rockefeller Bill Gates is down the
street Duffield
of PeopleSoft is at the end of the road
you know it just they're everywhere
these are all buildings that were built
with money that was not tuition money
now some of the money actually is
tuition money because yeah often don't
get the full donation thank you
shockingly smaller amounts but um but in
any case every dollar that one of those
rich bastards gives us like cysts Cindy
while gave us while Hall is money that
kid doesn't have to pay for and the
state doesn't have to pay from the
taxpayers don't have to pay for us so
it's like you know the huge foundation
so the question is is is that efficient
are we squandering money because that
it's possible but you know you know if
you look at a school like MIT right now
they're doing amazing things Stanford is
doing some amazing things when I say
amazing things different areas and and
so it's not obvious to me that the big
endowments are to be criticized because
Harvard for example you get so much aid
to go there
Harbor and I heard rumor said they were
gonna shut down in the fall because the
amount of money costs teepsy undergrads
from their cash flow it's cheaper for
them not to teach others and and so so
it's a subsidy for them and and so I
think you know we could get rid of a lot
of colleges replace them with tech
schools various you know I that the guy
who was fixing the elevator a year ago I
was talked into and he was still an
apprentice but he said after five years
he gets real pay said how much he said
over a hundred I should you become an
elevator repair guy or major in
sociology right that's the question I
think a lot of people the argument of
hey there's a big separation at the
higher education level of like the elite
schools have a very material serious
impact and kind of the economics there
make sense and you can measure what goes
in and what comes out but there's just
too many schools right which is a whole
nother level at school can't develop an
endowment one could make the argument
that that they're pointing out students
who are not extinguishing the cost of
the school right if the school's product
is is educated people if if they're
impoverished you know is it was it
really worth it I know there's humanists
we're gonna go back after a few minutes
well Harvard has humanities Cornell has
humanities they are a it's some level
kind of a social program that you can
afford to have if you were a financially
powerful school right in the olden days
schools just weren't expensive and so
you could actually and and by the way
someone who came to Cornell a hundred
years ago a major to philosophy look
like that they came from wealthy
families they came from families where
you can afford to do that and so it's a
very complicated mathematics to
understand colleges but I do
we're not wallowing in money people
think the endowment Harvard I sat with
the the the the assistant provost of
in the middle of the financial crisis
sitting in my office
and he really got pretty honest with me
there he says he says we don't know how
we're gonna make payroll and I know
Cornell had that problem and what it is
what people don't understand about the
endowments is it's not a big Harvard
centavos not a big 40 billion pot of
money it's not a 40 billion pile of of
equities it's this exceedingly complex
cordon off piles of things some of which
are illiquid assets they might be they
might own Timberland in Siberia right
guys you can't just liquidate that stuff
but a lot of its like for example my
salaries paid by the endowment and so
they can't just take the money that they
would have paid me so I it defers the
cost of me and and and and there's all
sorts of activities on campus that are
paid by the endowment you know that
lacrosse coaches an endowed coach you
know things like that and and and that
pays for that all pays for things that
we either could not afford or or or
would have to use tuition dollars to get
yeah your point also about kind of the
trade schools I've got a buddy who he
started to roll up a bunch of
electrician businesses and his idea
basically was look that's a school
that's not gonna get automated away by
robotics or anything and actually it's a
undesirable skill for most people so
there's not a lot of people who wake up
every day so I want to be electrician
it's a very technical skill and so
actually his belief is that the supply
of electricians will dwindle but the
demand will stay the same or actually go
up as we build more and therefore you
will actually kind of have an expanding
margin business and so he's been rolling
these things up and and you look at your
like look part of the problem is the the
trade schools right and the lack of them
and there's just not that many people
with those hard technical skills that
are needed because everyone either wants
to go you know kind of be educated in
other things or go be a software
engineer now right
the other thing is imagine you take a
smart guy and you send him off to one of
these trade schools and in the process
you teach them accounting in business
and things like that but meanwhile
they're also learning the plumbing and
the heating and the stuff like that you
take a Harvard smart kid and you put
them in a trade school and that guy's
gonna come out and do stuff and so one
of the really difficult things is they
talk about this sort of the financial
benefits of a Harvard degree what's very
difficult to tease apart they try they
don't they're not oblivious to this it's
hard to tease apart is what happens if
you take a Harvard smart kid who didn't
go to Harvard right and and well they
would have probably gone off and done
some pretty cool stuff and so you know
and we you know Gates didn't finish
Harvard right and so so they can go
change the world and one of the problems
that when when you when you graduate
with a lot of debt is are you gonna
change the world or are you gonna go get
a job and a cubicle to pay off your
student loans and how many of those guys
like if gates and come from a poor
family let's say Annie went to Harvard
he bill up student debt how many of
those guys would you have to divert from
starting the next Microsoft or the next
PeopleSoft or whatever and instead send
them to a cubicle to maybe become CEO of
a company we couldn't give a damn about
how many those diversions does it take
to have a measurable impact on they're
kind of mean the answer is trivial
number right so I think that I think I
think hobbling a generation with debt is
a disaster I think giving free college
is a disaster because I can also see
kids squandering an opportunity so I
think there's got to be blood on the
page I don't know how much I don't know
how to do it I think the Democrats have
it have the idea right the method wrong
I think I think we gotta learn how to
make stuff right we gotta we gotta we
gotta I think what Trump had dead right
his head right the whole way is to sort
of bring manufacturing back to the US
to quit outsourcing because when you pay
other people to make the stuff the cash
flows that direction we just can't keep
doing that
yes I'm like Kyle bass he would say that
- he hates Trump but he would say that's
correct
so I did a conversation with Kyle and he
didn't hold back at all for sure he does
not hold back he's been actually a nice
resource too because when I asked him a
question he doesn't he doesn't hold back
yeah we're serving that I've really
enjoyed the conversation it was
fantastic I got about what's going on in
China and the COBIT is that what you
talked about it was it earlier this was
earlier than that and and he was still
this is around the Hong Kong protests
and all that pretty bearish yeah I've
got four questions for you to finish up
two of them came from the audience that
were really good and then to ask
everybody the first one from the
audience was if you were in your early
20s
what would you invest your time and
money in right now I saw this on Twitter
I went through all the answers on
Twitter whoever asks that question was a
good one
first and foremost I tell young guys to
not worry about this [ __ ] that I worry
about that it going down that rabbit
hole ISM it's in your 20s it's not the
time to do it it's it's leave it to the
old guys to [ __ ] about the government
and and there's also question what do
you invest in and and it's a little more
ambiguous to me because when I try to do
is I say it looks pumping up a 60-40
that no one no one has the cojones to
balance of portfolio by selling the
winners and buying the losers so what I
tend to do is I said look at the end of
each year look at how lopsided it has
gotten and switch your allocation over
and and and so you don't sell anything
you just move you if bonds are like
going with bonds right and and and then
and then the problem is is one time I
was in the middle of a podcast I said
you know someone who can do this you
know send it to me what would happen if
you started buying the
in 1989 if you started now if you're a
55 year old businessman and you're in
the Nikkei and 89 you went to your grave
without getting even right you were in a
world of trouble that's what the modern
investors don't seem to see I I think
that's where husband's dead right we are
in so much risk right now but what
happens if you bought the Nikkei
starting in 1989 and you spotted all the
way down and back up it took you 22
years to breaki that's a long time so
I'm a little torn with the idea of just
just start averaging it and don't worry
about it I would say do you find a good
financial adviser and they're rare
because they all think they're good I've
got some sites on a few for when when I
finally turned out to be right you know
the blind not finds the squirrel
occasionally and again America cinnamon
was gonna get is gonna get some of my
money group called Manning in the pier
that's gonna get some more I really
would rather not handle my own money but
I reached the point I said I can't turn
this over to the to the street
when people ask me about evaluating
financial advisors I tell them look the
first question that I would ask a
financial advisor just some of your
personal returns for the last five years
what do you personally doing because
they tell me everything I need to know
cuz you're not gonna look after my money
any better than looking after your own
well I wouldn't have same thing abuse
ago some money for example I think he's
been really good I want to see the
returns of someone through the boom
because I called Harvard's problem
because during the boom Harvard was
clearly getting hedge fund returns and I
said when this thing goes to hell
they're gonna get hedge fund returns too
and so I want to see a person who during
the wild and crazy' euphoria's
underachieved
I don't I just don't think there's many
traders out there and you know Talab
would say look in a Gaussian curve of
10,000 traders there's got to be some
so don't be deceived fooled by
randomness and and so I like to see I
like to see guys have muted returns
which is why Madoff was so criminal
because Madoff played into precisely the
kind of thinking that you should be you
should have you say I just want someone
who gives me solid steady returns and
that's what he gave that's why I made
yeah it was a get rich scheme yeah you
know by me these guys could they they
got what they deserved but Madoff's
clients just won and steady returns and
that's exactly what he gave them we look
it's Howard Marks right it's it's bad
Marx's got a head on his shoulders yeah
and what and I forget exactly the quote
but basically his whole theory is look I
never want to be the best returned right
in the year because that means I took so
much risk that if I was wrong I would
have been in the bottom of the returns
right I kind of want to just be above
average year after year after year and
I'll end up in the top 5% of all asset
managers of a long period of time if you
said you gotta take all your money and
do something with it
I'd probably just buy Berkshire even
today after it hasn't yeah I'll tell you
why because I got a figure that they're
so loaded down with goddamn companies
that are stable companies I've never
really looked at them carefully but they
they do call out the herd occasionally
they dumped a bunch of the airlines for
example Buffett could die and as we
talked about earlier the companies that
he bought still exist and I got a figure
that that even though they had a
disastrous attempt to find an heir
apparent about five years ago where the
guy committed some fraudulent [ __ ] and
got fired I gotta figure there's people
in the queue there who know how about
the thinks and knows how to do it i I
think the next bull market which is
going to come after the next bear market
I think we're just i think this rally is
so fake at some point there will be
bargains and I think that you will have
to buy equities that pay you to hold
them
not pay you because of some promise of
the future I think you want to buy some
company while avoiding dividend traps
pays you dividends I think you wanted to
be able to say look this company no debt
steady business 5% dividend I'll take it
yeah it's possible for sure the second
question was what mistakes you've made
in your life that taught you the most I
don't know how to define a mistake I
mean the reason is and I said this
before I send everything through a
filter and I've done this for most of my
life where I say if this goes very very
badly will I forgive myself and that
keeps me out of Bitcoin for example and
when people say I'll just buy a little I
go wool then it'll just do jack [ __ ] for
my return - so you know the idea of
owning 3% gold is insurance plus a go
there yeah yeah buy yourself a $5,000
insurance policies and see how your wife
does on that one so so I have to go with
if I blew this one will I forgive myself
and and then what happens is are they
mistakes right I'm not sure you call it
a mistake so investing wise I fought the
Fed and I think it was a legitimate
thing to do but I totally misunderstood
the utter insanity that they would
inflict upon us and and so and I'm not
gonna stop fighting him now because I
think they've got us hanging off a
precipice but I paid a price for
fighting the Fed and tapper trying to
tell me temper said you know I'm buying
what the fence by him but temper skills
I don't have giacomo his skills I don't
have so if you try to imitate those guys
you're gonna be you're gonna be that
this the smudge mark you're gonna be the
loser oh yeah by the way we liquidated
that and so what are the mistakes I've
made I really have so few
rats and I've tried to think about that
I've tried to think about what my life's
big disappointment was and it's so hard
to identify one and it's not that I blow
something I can rewrite history you know
I played lacrosse in high school and I
compared myself to peers on the team and
one southpaw attackman was clearly
better than me a guy older than man was
better than both of us in my opinion a
defenseman used to beat the [ __ ] out of
me every day and I was a gymnast too so
I was a small lacrosse player Senate
gymnast I just like gymnastics better so
I went to gymnastics I grew to six feet
bad idea
found out later that the guy who was the
southpaw was a three-time first-team
all-american in college the guy who was
way better than him never played college
ball so we'll never know what he was but
he was he would have been a legend and
the defenseman played he was a long
snapper for the Cowboys for 12 years
and so I I made the mistake of a
relative comparison I said well this is
not my sport these guys are clearly and
there was another defenseman a head I
know trouble with he went to Georgetown
employed right so I made a mistake of
using a relative calibration that was
wrong back but I like gymnastics better
I liked it better than lacrosse I wanted
to do gymnastics 12 months a year so I
did it is that I can look back and say I
should have trained this I wish I'd gone
to cross-handed putting you know I mean
there's these are big life's big
disappointments you've lived a good life
I don't think you can call those
disappointments yeah and it's it's a
world according to the babe right it's
it's it's such a weird and twisted route
and when I want to sort of go through a
biography oh god that's so goddamn
entertaining in some way so I I just I
don't have remorse but my mother was a
serious alcoholic like passed out cold
noon
Oh God corta Genoa
French I don't think it hurt me I don't
think it hurt my brother we became very
independent and my dad held everything
together well inside it you know I I
guess I'm probably a little more
sensitive to alcohol consumption but I I
don't know I you know if you'd asked my
brother and I when we were in high
school you know what would happen if
your dad right I think we both were said
we'd be fine he was financially stable
we knew there'd be money we also knew we
didn't need my mother I mean she would
she had her we loved her she was a
victim of this to Horn disease and she
uh she always loved us there was never a
doubt about that so there was just no
scarring um I was told someone I had to
be scarred so I read a book adult
children of alcoholics I was like 1.5
for 21 on the checklist
the tickles you can't finish a task you
know a lot of failures and I'm gonna no
no no the ones that came at one point I
was like overachieving things yeah okay
but maybe I'm just an overachiever right
maybe I just like to achieve that that
does happen you lose right so I don't
control that and I don't it doesn't I
don't think about having a tough
childhood or anything
I don't just you know what some sense
the independence was great mom's best I
would go get shit-faced ourselves right
we can go get stoned we can go you do
things we can go you know get in trouble
I was hitchhiking at 12 my mother would
say you know when she had a license I'd
say can I have a ride she said you had a
thumb don't you we did and and those
were great days those were phenomenal
days you know we play sports every day
after school and it was just I have such
fun memories for childhood College was
phenomenal
I worked my ass off and done this job
for for 41 years without losing federal
support that's any chemist Italian
that's this that's like Madonna right
you know that's like still cut in albums
at 60 and now I I haven't been able to
think of a big mistake that that that I
really had to learn from if the only
thing you can think of is that you
fought the Fed you're in good company
but uh what's the most important book
that you've ever read oh Jesus
the most important book well since I'm
an atheist I can't say the Bible the
most important book I've ever read
there's kind of a genre that I like I
like the neuropsych I like history this
most important book I finished one
recently I'm getting a little putty
headed in my old age I finished one I
just finished a book that I'm gonna have
to read again by Peter Bogosian and it's
the guy who faked all the the the
grievance studies papers you know the
guy who committed the fraud and
submitted him and gendered dogs at dog
parks and stuff like that i chat with
him occasionally and he wrote a book
about how to have difficult
conversations and it could be a
profoundly important book I give it a
plug and he talks about all the ways we
bomb conversations and and you know
words that are going into and not
knowing what what the goal is in the
conversation I got to read it again but
that could be one of the more important
was the book that that charlie munger
reference recommended was from the genre
the neuro psych the book influences so
it's a 1996 book I think and Charlie
said that's the most important book and
that grouping is good learning about
bias ism
mission and how how the brain works well
the most entertaining was unbroken about
Louie Zamperini that was a phenomenal
book ghost soldiers was a phenomenal
book about saving I do all nonfiction
the fiction I've read makes me
projectile vomit
so I Ollie you got to read the Chi RAM
it just doesn't work for me so I want to
get to the end of a book to feel smarter
maybe it's too so that when I'm having
the conversation with someone I can
molest them with my wonderfulness or
something I don't know you know that's
who knows what it is but I I don't like
I don't like any other book and finding
out that someone killed someone right
I'm trying to get through u.s. history
through the biographies of presidents
and and and someone were a little tricky
to find good books on but audiobooks
how's that I'm gonna answer that
question saying audiobooks yeah I I find
it very difficult to read these days
because I'm so attracted to audiobooks I
just feel like I'm cramming information
in my head you commute you come on or do
not but I listen to them when when I go
run or workout right okay a mistake I
made after being in great shape up to
about forty five I quit working out some
in wretched shape and then that arguably
a big mistake but I haven't learned from
yet still a wretched shape I got like
twenty four hours a week and then I had
some health problems that got in my way
and then I just I couldn't rally back
and now it's just like so last question
for you then you get to ask me a
question believer in aliens or not I
mean anywhere or having visited the
earth let's do both
statistically somewhere certainly got a
Manfred eigen who's a Nobel Prize
winning physicist I did some quick math
and and said if you look at just
the odds that there's just overwhelming
odds are out there I don't think they
can get here I think that uh you know
maybe or the other thing this is what
someone made this case was it a Rogen
interview or something well here's what
might be like I want to get him Rogen no
offense I'm gonna get it Rogan um we try
to help what's that
we'll try to help well I got a
connection with him on Twitter but so
far I'm sitting at the phone he's there
cold did you see the news today he he
signed a exclusive licensing deal with
Spotify so later this year his content
previously has not been available on
Spotify so now it's gonna be available
but later this year he's gonna go
exclusive to Spotify it's like Howard
Stern move yes so my guess is Howard was
actually the the contract numbers that I
used so they got to be paying 100 mil a
year right Grogan's got any bigger than
Howard Stern at this point and Howard
Stern I mean back in 2004 signed a
five-year five hundred million dollar
contract and he's still doing it so
fascinating Rogan so fascinating so one
day I wouldn't want to do a spy Rogan I
used to have a good back kick but Rogan
I look at a guy he would break me in
half with his back that's how I'm gonna
get him to bring you I'm gonna say
listen Dave said that he promised he's
got a scare and when I was told after
the fact when I noticed it I said all
the crap
someone said yeah he's known for it and
I go okay now that makes sense because
it sure as hell looks lethal I mean he
would just snap you like a pretzel than
that bad kick and I love backaches oh my
god when I was like what now it's just
bad kick was you just you can end a
match faster the back kick that guy goes
down what's the question you have sent
don't you ins you said aliens right I
don't think they can get here some some
podcast or something said what it's
possible they're here they said
imagine you're an aunt and you walk and
maybe this is Scott Adams or something
man your aunt you walk across a highway
you would have no idea that that that
was a sign of intelligent life because
you're not qualified you just don't have
the brains understand he said that the
highways could be all around us right
and and we just can't see them because
we're just the idea that we've hit hit
the limit of intelligence that's
certainly false it might be true but
it's only because we lose something
badly and so but but my current thinking
would be I don't think they can get here
I think the universe has separated us
enough that that that I don't think and
they they sure so I don't think they're
here now I don't think the UFOs are
here's the question I have is why are we
seeing it I bet you've noticed this why
are we seeing all these reports coming
out of official sources of UFOs yes so
there's two things that are very
interesting one is all the UFO things
that recently came out those have been
leaked before now they're just being
confirmed by the Air Force
yeah so it's a little weird that you
would choose now to confirm that stuff
but okay that's fine the second thing
that I think is very interesting is the
whole idea of a space force I feel like
that's kind of been flying under the
radar like we've literally set up a
government a habit I mean I got a figure
we just have it we're just codifying it
somehow right
well they look I saw a picture of the
person who's supposed to lead it right
that they got out there he's you know
some general or whatever you know what a
person and so this whole idea of like
wait a minute if we don't have any idea
or any knowledge or any information on
anything being you know out in space why
the hell are we creating a space force
right so you know you could ask why did
we go to the moon and the answer to that
question is so that we could develop
what it took to bomb the hell out of the
Russian
and and sell it to the American people
so I think I think a space force is to
give some Flair to something that they
want to spend a lot of money on and want
to have a good cover for I think the
idea of the release of the the UFOs from
official sources tells me they're trying
to distract us for something I I don't
know what you could imagine I'm kind of
a fourth turning guy and you could
imagine that the the people in power are
getting nervous at the the temperament
of the average person right the average
person is mad for those who don't know
the fourth turning you know it's the
idea you know there's an eight year
cycle broken into roughly four 20 year
cycles and then the fourth turnings the
bad one and that's where bad stuff
happens and then and then when at the
end you have green shoots and things
sort of and if you look at the US
history it probables a perfect eight
year cycle so you go back to the
depression you go back to Civil War you
go back to the Revolutionary War and the
one they don't mention in the book you
go back to the Salem witch trials and so
they wrote the book in 96 and said if
all goes according to plan the next
fourth turning should arrive pretty much
on schedule around 2010 and you should
take a holy [ __ ] and in it in the book
they say things weird weirdly prophetic
things where they say you know the
trigger could be anything from a
financial crash and they said a tea
party and I'm going what did you mean by
that right a tea party yes we have one
but how did you know that right just
like grass it's like that who's the guy
Nostradamus it's like ghost Radames
prediction and but I think if you say
when did the fourth turning appear if
you buy the model would it appear you
say well it's the financial crisis right
no actually I think the fourth turning
was or because of our failure to deal
with the financial crisis correctly so
we desperately needed to hang bad guys
by their balls
we desperate
needed and every other financial crisis
we rounded up the rascals possibly a
tiny fraction of all but enough of a war
we could say look we've we've cleanse
the system an average Joe can say okay
I'm fine you got the bad guys now we can
move on and we all came out of it all
the way up to the top of Wall Street
came out of it gone [ __ ] we did nothing
Jon Corzine what a great example that
guy should have been hung and and we got
nothing and Oh a great book by I'm oh
Christ
Jesse Eisenberg the Jesse Eisenberg book
it's new pretty new it's about what was
going on I read every crisis book I
thought there's note I can lip-synch on
what a credit default swap is right so
boring Eisinger talked about what was
going on in the Department of Justice
and in the regulatory agencies during
the crisis it was a completely
refreshingly new so I recommend that
book and it's an audio book by the way
and that's a great book and what
happened was is that we went out a
couple of these guys and failed now we
went we got a couple and then that the
appeals courts just completely
overturned and rake-off I think was the
judge was pissed off because he said we
spend months and months and months
putting this case together and some
goddamn appeals court spends a couple
hours look at the date and overturns him
and so what happened is the spine of the
justice system wasn't helped by holder
being in charge the spine was just
ripped out of it so they started
settling for the Oh we'll just find him
and they were happy with that they don't
care if the shareholders pay but even a
new it knows that when the shareholders
paid and get the right guys you got the
shareholders and so I think that we are
still very very much but hurt by the
failure to get anybody and so this
crisis has a lot of risk in it because
now we're really hurting the little guy
in a very unusual way and it still looks
like we're bailing out the big guys and
so so at some point we can have a
serious shitstorm the kind where you say
you didn't
she coming violence in the street sort
of thing the thing that I do think has
some credence to it I do not you know
and to be clear I don't think the virus
was a response to this but if you go
back five months six months there was
protests all over the world right and
all of a sudden everyone get inside now
again I don't think that the virus had
any connection in terms of doing that
but what I do think is that it's how
quickly forget literally you could go
down the list of all these places who
have this social unrest and now that we
start to get towards a financial crisis
in the United States and globally I
continue to say that $1200 stimulus
check that's a bribe to keep the social
unrest at bay right and it's a tiny tiny
tiny fraction of the total money that's
been allocated so if you see ways that
the money's being wasted send it to
because I'm trying to collect up all the
stupid stuff that they're really I've
got a great article about the wasted
money from a previous bailout where they
laid it on they said you really want to
know where the money when they went bang
bang bang bang bang through I want to
write that chapter this December and so
so I'm trying to collect it what's
interesting is they've been able to hide
the kind of really nasty levels of greed
in this one and and you know I think
what happened in oh eight oh nine by the
way when they bailed out all the banks
and and I get thee you had to save the
banking system I do get that but
afterwards the mission of hugging the
people from the bridge I think the
reason that the guys like blank fine and
all the bankers gave himself huge
bonuses which was so tasteless it was so
such that optics I think they thought
the system was doomed and they were just
saying we're gonna take one more wide
and run get out of here
and then I'll something look at me or
waiter when we saw jobs there's still
money holy cow we didn't even need to do
that part of it this time that is pretty
interesting is one
they almost learned from the last crisis
so you don't see the you know you don't
see Paulson going in front of a panel of
people asking hard questions right so
you kind of cut a
none of that is hey let's get into this
before we go what bothers me so much
about this crisis is its providing cover
for all the bad behavior it's just it it
is breaking my heart that bad politics
are being covered bad economics you're
being covered everything's being covered
and in in my as you know I'm willing to
go into dark places and ponder self
Aristotle Senate an educated man can
enter can entertain an idea without
endorsing it and I can endorse him right
I can endorse the idea that I've seen
may not be dead
I can endorse the idea that the Vegas
shootings were all screwed up I wrote
about that and I I had a fasting lunch
with Einhorn's mother and father there's
a connected world for you and she said
that my write-up on the Vegas shootings
was so haunting because every shred of
those right so I can endorse weird stuff
I don't know I don't know if it's
possible enough but could you take a
normal sort of a flu-like thing and turn
it into a massive storyline to achieve
because it comes again if you know you
got a bailout of corporate debt bubble
you know okay let's let's make hay out
of this because we're gonna have to do
it we got to get people to sign off so
you know you let the Japanese hit Pearl
Harbor so you can go to war you let you
know you sink the Lusitania so you can
go to war this happens all the time and
so um so I don't really know if it could
be that good but here's a question I'd
like to ask myself than I like to ask
others think of big sample sizes that
you can name for which people are not
dying so let's start with Ithaca forty
thousand people know dead people not a
dead person right I go god you know for
a profoundly virulent strain of
awfulness know dead people then you say
okay okay maybe that's it the guy the I
think it was the NBA of the NFL tested
all of their staff the intended
secretaries recruiters everything
thousands of people from what 26 cities
or something right this is a pretty
interesting sample size point seven
percent positive ID antibodies I'm going
how is that possible
the here's what I really like this think
of all the famous people you know and
they're no I just famous people but
they're famous positions so for example
we don't know all the congressman but
there's 535 of them and one of them dies
that's a headline 100 senators 50
governors right you go on and on heads
of state
you know ambassadors to countries
professional athletes Hollywood famous
tyrant starlets
there's thousands named one who's died
can you that's a real interesting
problem well I'll give you one google it
you get [ __ ] I'll give you one even
better
the recent stat I saw was if you compare
Florida and New York State so Florida
actually has like it's like two or three
million more people than need oh guys
and they're old and all the stuff and
New York State has many many more deaths
I forget the exact number but if you
look at the headlines you would think
that Florida they had the beaches open
you know they weren't paying attention
they weren't taking it seriously right
kind that whole narrative but the data
is actually showing that Florida has
fared better than your Sweden or Sweden
so here's the problem if we get to the
end of this thing and this this is it
so we've declared we're gonna open and
we crawl our way out and there is no
second wave and there is no killing
field there is no anything and by the
way those sample size I was talking
about bother me because because because
if you needed to pull off kind of a hoax
and I don't mean to say that it's all a
hoax but rather amplified it could be
one of these things where it's like wow
you know I don't know anyone but it must
be other people do you know and and and
so it would be easy to convince someone
that while you don't know but but
they're out there there's a
five 90 whatever thousand who have died
from this um we have four nursing homes
in town no died in there I don't know
how this can be happening with the
storyline that we're getting and so then
the question is can you go so far as to
say that maybe they're amplifying it so
there's three levels one is that there's
just human stupidity so maybe we
responded badly under some set of
conditions
there's opportunism so once it hits it
oh boy now we can get you know cheap
loans on the Fed and then the worst one
is the one where you create the effect
and this could be for example get Trump
right how many people out there how many
authorities are out there are promoting
to maintain sheltering because they know
it'll hurt Trump and in November now
those people again they're on my hit
list those are people who are so immoral
they don't realize how sociopathic they
are they don't realize that they're
throwing and and how many people are
thinking well you know the good news is
we're gonna get Trump if this goes this
way and therefore I'm supporting
sheltering look you are a sick sick
person if you want to do that because we
are caught we are destroying lives as
we're as you and I were gonna be fine
right if you're a Bitcoin it you can buy
and sell me but but but these people are
suffering badly and there's thing called
deaths of despair and supposedly there's
a lot of them in any given year and
their deaths that are ultimately tied to
poverty right whether it's opioid deaths
or things like that the question is are
they gonna spike and the glamorous one
is the suicide right the guy who's this
jumps off a cliff or whatever but
there's just deaths of despair where
just your life goes to hell what one
minute you're employed the next minute
you're homeless and how do you count
them in but but there are academic
papers I hate use that phrase that
people have studied deaths of despair to
try to get their brains around how how
serious this problem is we're
a lot of that did you see the video I
tweeted it I think yesterday where there
was a cop who showed up two cops showed
up to a gym in New Jersey so obviously
New Jersey still in shelter-in-place
a gym owner basically said look I had
enough I'm not playing this game anymore
I'm open in my gym and he put the word
out a bunch of people had showed up
there was zero social distancing going
on there was a couple of people with
masks right but for the most part they
were violating all the rules cop had a
mask on and he walks in the in front of
the gym and you could tell it was kind
of some kind of either the gym owner the
police somebody tipped off somebody
because there was a lot of media there
right and so they're all filming this
and the cop walks into the middle of the
whole thing and he says you know because
everyone shut up
everyone gets quiet and he says listen I
am here to formally tell you that you
are violating the executive order to
stay sheltered in place you guys have a
nice day though and he walks right well
so it's a like cops are normal people -
right and so yeah I think I think
somehow society often just said that's
it part of the thing that reminds them
to do that it's because they walk in the
store and there's the guys work in the
store and they're not flopping over and
and they're not gonna hazard pay and
they're not so this guy's working why is
a store essential we couldn't find an
optometrist explain to me why if our my
glasses are broken that's not essential
so I think we're done look at the police
department I mean one of the most
interesting stats I didn't see where
they talked about was at one point it
was like 18 or 19 percent of the NYPD
was calling in sick right and and part
of it is look they've got the vacation
time some of it's probably just fear of
hey I'm not going to work and getting
you know this thing I'm actually or sick
right when you start talking about a job
we're literally your job is to go
interact with people to shake hands so
you know do all these things and I saw
it was Seattle a cop basically was
sitting in this car in his uniform and
it sounded like he just had enough he
put on his phone
he recorded something and he said look
if you are a police officer remember
your job is to protect and serve the
people you cannot you know violate the
Constitution and Bobo autostart what he
gets put on paid leave right right
exactly and and and and I think people
are now watching that so I think that
was ultimately probably what led to this
gigantic sort of paroxysm to use a
stockman term where society just said
we've had enough and it happened in
about a three-day period it was so fast
and I think it could be something like
that blonde hair stylist or something I
don't know but but then the questions of
let's say we open up and then nothing
else happens everything I know about
herd immunity says if we had to have it
we don't yet have it and if we already
have it we didn't need to shut down so
there's a real paradoxical problem here
if and if it reappears then we're
screwed royally I'll leave you with my
biggest fear coming out of all of this
which is you get one shot to educate and
train a population to do quarantine the
right way if there is a second virus not
coronavirus I can wait wait a real the
two five million people whatever it is
are actually gonna die I believe that it
will be nearly impossible to walk down
the United States a second time because
people will be so anchored on this
experience and that's my other fear
though is is every time there's any kind
of thing coming out of China or Africa
we're gonna shut everything down we
can't keep doing this this would be like
trying to accrue wealth while bulldozing
your house every five years right so we
can't people now I don't think we'll do
this again so I agree with you when
there if this is a if this is a false
start then then then then then the next
we're all gonna die from because people
are gonna buy it I've been trying to
figure out what the optimum is so it
started way back when
thinking okay so so what I can tell you
this if they shout everything down and
nothing happens we have a problem if
they shut everything down and we all die
we have a problem somewhere in the
middle is the best outcome I don't know
how many dead people we need and how
convincing a case we need somehow I
think people to be okay
are gonna have to say we're okay but we
had to do it I get it
I've sacrificed let's move on right it's
it's like when your kid gets killed
fighting in World War two whereas if
your kid gets killed fighting in Vietnam
and you're going you know they're both
horrible but one is one is worse than
the other we somehow need to be able to
come to terms with what we have just
sacrificed and look and part of the the
really sad part right is we'll never
know because at the end of the day if we
hadn't done the quarantine the shelter
in place we'll never know what the
impact would have been disagree though
because I think the sheltering puts it
off so I think remember there was a
mission creep here we're the first
they're going to shelter us so that we
didn't overwhelm our healthcare system
then alphadon became clearly overwhelmed
almost nothing you know the horrible
pictures out of New York my wife's been
in New York hospitals they're
overwhelmed not a good day and so so I'm
not sure and I got a bad flu they get
overwhelmed and so so so then else it
turned into now we're gonna shelter just
so no one dies and that's not what we
signed off on right and and so so I do
think that if if sheltering hammered the
virus down we have to have a second wave
I will not be able to come to terms with
the idea that we can go we can hide from
it and come out and it's gone this is
the remember the movie 28 days a zombie
movie what was amazing about this
they'll ran out of energy it's most
realistic zombie movie they all ran out
of energy right you can't just keep
running around forever
the virus can run around forever and so
I think that if we all come out and it
doesn't flare back up then it's gonna be
shown to be a knee-jerk reaction that
was totally inappropriate it's
forgivable in the sense that we didn't
know but it's gonna look like a scroll
I'm asked drunken Millers a hold
perspective or anything he came out and
he said look he thinks that in hindsight
again to your point with the information
we had it probably was the right
decision but in hindsight when we get
information people will look back and
they'll basically say this is one of the
worst public policy decisions that was
ever made now again hindsight bias and
hindsight is you know 20/20 but but
hearing him say that of all people I
thought was pretty interesting yeah he's
he's so good if I had to sort of send a
message to the future and say okay next
time next time the first thing I would
do is I would go very local so I'd say
first of all I say the governors have
the ultimate say hey and and and and
even more local than that maybe where
where where there's much more authority
for it you know say look of course we
had students I made it very complicated
but but preferred time to say look we
got no cases here we can keep working
and to have a governor say you can't
work that was insane
some guy wrote an article to his
governor from South Dakota or something
he said we've had six deaths he named
their ages he says it was a doctor he
said there you know 59s he signed 72
done another he says we've lost this
many jobs thousands tens of thousands he
said he said you have to open this up he
said this is an insane calculation
you're doing here and and I've been told
that up in Maine friend of mine is up in
Maine says that you wouldn't know there
was a pandemic up in Maine so they're
kind of doing this we all live by New
York standards a lot of us were New York
City standards and I think the message
there will be no shelter where you have
to shelter I'd stop interstate travel
that would mix us
so say look just stop crossing the
borders right so I'm gonna leave you
with one stat before we go which is I
believe that this is still true the
average death or the average age of
people who have died from Kovan is
higher than the average age of people
who died in the United States well
here's a weirder stat the fatality rate
of nurses in the United States which
admittedly not all deal with common but
the ones who are dealing with comedor
all nurses is 10 fall lower than the
average the average fatality rate of the
country as a whole so the nurses have
and here's a stat for you in a typical
year eight hundred doctors died of the
flu how many doctors if we've been
reading about her hearing about on CNN
or whatever how many died of this maybe
heddle - right their faces they'd be
heroes they'd be we we're not hearing
about the day they're there I've seen
them not eight hundred so I worry that
underneath this thing is is politics
yeah and not just late appearing but but
appearing earlier than then they should
have appeared you were pouchy do it
you trust Falchi I think that he is if I
had to put a category you have to put
him in a politician's bucket because he
is serving as the mouthpiece with a
megaphone for an entire community since
Reagan's first term he's been he's been
a politician since Reagan's first term
so what I will say is I don't believe
that he is like maliciously going up
there and saying I know one thing in my
head but I'm saying something 180 degree
difference but if you're on that podium
your politician right and so there's
there's there's massage
the message there's you know kind of
let's highlight this data not this other
data all that stuff goes on across both
aisles anyone who gets up on that podium
they're all the same right for the most
part and so the fact that it is a doctor
I don't think is you know absolves you
of those sins to some degree so the
question will be will the politics that
inspired us to open up prove to be
greater than the politics that were
inspiring us to stay sheltered which was
more which was a stronger political
force which was more political so I
gotta go back I don't want to say who I
think tweeted this very early on in case
I'm incorrect somebody who it's got a
pretty big following on Twitter and I'll
send it to you afterwards if if it ends
up being right and I think I remember
him saying when they were starting to
lock down China he said something to the
effect of quarantine would never work in
the United States because people are too
kind of religious or too much of a
zealot or the American indifferent
ideals and so I think that what ends up
prevailing in these situations is what
was the default it's less about you know
lockdown versus reopen up it's much more
about the default is always open up and
therefore that undercurrent kind of
Rises and ultimately look you know Egypt
what was the uprising people needed to
eat right you know you kind of get into
this game of you know I've said multiple
times on Twitter the number one thing
that a governor shouldn't have done on
day one is said shut down your
businesses I'm going to suspend taking
my salary until you reopen your business
were all in this together I won't ask
you to do something I won't do right
what not one of the 50 governors did I
would have been a politically good move
especially for Cuomo I mean imagine
imagine if he had done that your day
want people to love them yeah yeah so
that's that's an interest that's an
interesting idea that and then the other
one videos who did stuff like that there
were a couple of CEOs who did some stuff
I can't remember it but something like
look it's a thing where I believe right
[ __ ] this is punch the political are
the politicians who end up ascending
very quickly moving forward are going to
be people who have an overlap of skills
both in influential leadership of people
so no more of the kind of authoritative
leadership but much more hey I'm not
going to tell you that you're being
legally forced to stay inside but I'm
asking you as a responsibility of as an
American citizen save your neighbor by
staying inside type stuff and then to is
command of the social platforms right
their ability to speak directly to their
constituents Trump AOC right I mean
there's people on both sides of the
aisle that have that ability but I do
think that that next kind of class over
of politicians are gonna be very very
talented at it so what's the silver
linings I'll start it knocked AOC off
the news
it knocked climate change out of there
for a while I was getting pretty tired
of hearing about that it knocked a lot
of the social justice crap you know
you're sitting there trying to figure
out if your pronouns right and and and
and and everyone else does and excuse me
I just don't want to die right so I I
think there's some silver lining any
other silver linings that jump out of
just like it yeah
it made us more efficient at it online
communication but I'm not sure that's
the silver lining it might ultimately be
kind of a numbing effect so I think I
would go with one much more focus on
nationalism and a lot of people I think
look at nationalism is binary
it's either nationalism or globalism but
just reminded people that hey you can't
go help the rest of the world at that if
you're not taking care of at home right
put on your oxygen mask first yeah so I
think that was definitely one lesson out
of this the second is a complete revival
of this idea of Technology and science
and building and just hey wait a second
we were
hosted for a while there we suck frankly
as a as a country on many many levels
cuz we fall asleep at the wheel
right I think that this is local so a
lot of local communities kind of pulled
their [ __ ] together and realized that
you know I remember after 9/11 there was
a story about a pilot who went out on
one of the first flights the pilot went
on he said when when those doors go
closed it's just us we're gonna make
sure we get there and it was some sense
saying you know some terrorists can't
can't do damage to us because it's just
us and so so I think it's some sense
communities have picked up a sense of
community realizing that there's some
things you have to do local and I'm kind
of hoping that there's got to be people
who can't get food there's got to be
tons who can't get food because they
were barely getting food before kind of
hoping communities pick up where where
churches left off right I'm actually I'm
the only a theist in history to write
about the merits of religion but I think
we've picked up a renewed sense of
community I also believe out of oh wait
oh nine crisis there was a complete
disdain for wall street and the banks
coming this crisis there will be a very
very deep disdain for government I think
a lot of people are gonna come out of
this and they're basically gonna point
and say look the virus didn't shut down
my business you did right and I think
it's gonna be people from both sides of
the aisles right that they'd say look I
vote Republican Democrat independent you
know whatever it is and they're just
gonna say look at the end of the day you
took my livelihood from me right a
percentage aren't coming back Neal -
that's a big deal so all right where can
people find you on on the Internet where
can they go read and listen to all of
your intelligent brain if so uh send me
an email they can my email box is big
wieldy but they come you can find me
the only rational place to find me is is
at Twitter which is a David B column my
my pin tweet is my annual Year in Review
which somehow seems to have played a
role in getting me onto these this on
this different plane that it started out
it's just a few thoughts to a few
friends garage band blog and and now
it's gotten pretty big and so uh yeah
David be calling at Twitter and uh and
then you know podcasts and stuff right
so the the annual litter is uh is
fantastic I highly suggest anyone to go
read it well thank you yeah so listen we
will we will do this again and anyone
write it it's really like passing a
bowling ball through your urethra every
year yeah alright my friend we'll do
this again okay